Welcome to our second drink of Goodbye Toby, Part 2. So much happens in this episode. It's like the season four cliffhanger. Yes. And while we did our best to cover everything, some of you wrote in with story moments that you wished we had covered. Like Jory L. wrote in to say, I'm kind of sad they didn't mention the voicemail Jim left Ryan.
欢迎来到我们《再见托比》第二部分的第二杯。这一集里发生了太多事。就像第四季的悬念一样。是的。虽然我们尽力涵盖了所有内容，但你们中有些人写信来提到了一些你们希望我们涵盖的剧情时刻。比如Jory L.写信说，他们没提到吉姆留给瑞安的语音留言，我感到有点难过。
It was so funny. Oh my God, it is so funny. Okay, so it's right after Ryan gets arrested and it's a major Jim Sass. Well, I think we need to hear it. Hey, Ryan, it's Jim. You know what? Totally disregard that last voicemail because you obviously have your hands tied. Good luck. Get it? He has his hands tied. Right, not hands full. Yeah, because he's just been cuffed. Right. Jim Sass! All right, I wanted to share something fun that I found on disc four from season nine. It's in that section called A Look Back. It's like a compilation. It's a tearjerker when you watch it. We've talked about it in the finale episode. But there was a moment where Ed Helms talks about the proposal scene between Andy and Angela. Oh, that happens in this episode. That happens in this episode.
那太搞笑了。天哪，真的太搞笑了。好吧，那是在瑞安被捕之后，那是吉姆典型的讽刺。嗯，我觉得我们需要听听看。嘿，瑞安，我是吉姆。你知道吗？完全忽略掉那条语音留言，因为你显然被束缚住了。祝你好运。懂吗？他被束缚住了。对，不是手忙脚乱。是的，因为他刚被戴上手铐。对。吉姆的讽刺！好了，我想分享一些我在第九季第四张光盘上发现的有趣内容。它在那个叫“回顾”的部分。就像一个合集。看的时候很催泪。我们在大结局那一集里谈到过。但有一个片段是艾德·赫尔姆斯谈论安迪和安吉拉的求婚场景。哦，那发生在这一集。那发生在这一集。
Again, I'm hugely pregnant. They're trying to hide it. But here's some of Ed's memories of that moment. I think the scene where Andy proposed to Angela was very fitting because it was so left-footed and just awkward. Angela's response was not good. It really summed up the tension, the misunderstanding, the denial, all these awful things that kind of underpinned. their relationship. Mm-hmm.
再说一次，我当时怀孕很明显。他们试图遮掩。但这是艾德对那一刻的一些回忆。我觉得安迪向安吉拉求婚的那一幕非常贴切，因为它显得那么笨拙和尴尬。安吉拉的反应并不好。它真的总结了紧张、误解、否认，所有这些支撑着他们关系的糟糕事情。嗯。
All true. That response was horrible. Like, well, you marry, just like, okay. Sure. I know. Well, listen, we also got a fan mail flurry for this episode. Folks really needed me to know that the Dan band is not in the movie The Wedding Singer. I said they were in the wedding singer.
全都是真的。那个反应太糟糕了。就像，嗯，你结婚，就像，好吧。当然。我知道。好吧，听着，我们这一集也收到了大量的粉丝来信。大家真的需要让我知道“丹乐队”（The Dan Band）并没有出现在电影《婚礼歌手》里。我说过他们出现在《婚礼歌手》里。
They were, in fact, in the hangover and old school. Thank you so much. I think I was thinking of old school. But I also just recently rewatched The Hangover, and they are also in that. Yeah. Which, by the way, The Hangover is a bonkers movie. Bonkers. How much can happen to those group of guys?
事实上，他们出现在了《宿醉》和《重返校园》里。非常感谢。我想我当时想到的是《重返校园》。但我最近也重温了《宿醉》，他们也出现在那部电影里。是的。顺便说一句，《宿醉》是一部疯狂的电影。疯狂。那群家伙身上到底能发生多少事？
My God. So much. So funny. All those guys are so funny. Ed is so funny in it. Ed is amazing in it. Lastly, a lot of you wrote in about how much you loved the Alt Michael Goodbye Toby songs that Paul Lieberstein wrote.
天哪。太多了。太搞笑了。那些家伙都太搞笑了。艾德在里面太搞笑了。艾德在里面太棒了。最后，你们很多人写信说你们有多喜欢保罗·利伯斯坦写的迈克尔版《再见托比》的替代歌曲。
Jenna, you had shared this with us, and we actually had Josh, my husband, sing Bears in Heaven and Jordan Duffy sing totally eclipse of the fart. Yes. And we played those in the episode, but we never actually played the song that aired, the one that Michael sings to Toby. It happens and starts and stops because there's talking heads that interrupt it. But a bunch of folks online have pieced it all together so you can hear it as one. Yes.
珍娜，你和我们分享过这个，我们实际上让我的丈夫乔什唱了《天堂里的熊》，让乔丹·达菲唱了《屁之全蚀》。是的。我们在那一集里播放了这些，但我们从未真正播放过播出的那首歌，就是迈克尔唱给托比听的那首。它断断续续地进行，因为中间有采访片段打断了它。但网上一群人把它拼凑在一起，这样你就可以完整地听到了。是的。
It's so crazy. I forgot how crazy the song is. Here's one that was compiled by Randy M. It was early morning yesterday. I was up before the dawn. And I really have enjoyed my stay. Toby must be moving on. Goodbye, Toby just started finally watching the office from the beginning with my two kids.
太疯狂了。我忘了这首歌有多疯狂了。这是兰迪·M整理的一首。那是昨天清晨。我在黎明前就起床了。我真的很享受我的停留。托比必须继续前行。《再见托比》刚开始和我的两个孩子从头看《办公室》。
Oh, how's it going? Okay, we're in the middle of season three. I cannot wait for them to see that. Because they love how much Michael hates Toby. My kids, of course, love Dwight. My son laughed so hard. You know when conflict resolution, when Michael's reading off all of Dwight's complaints, and the thing about like, I hit myself in the head with the phone. And Michael's like, how would that have been Jim's fault? And then Jim explains the coins, the weighted headset.
哦，进展如何？好吧，我们看到第三季中期了。我迫不及待想让他们看到那一幕。因为他们喜欢迈克尔有多讨厌托比。我的孩子们当然喜欢德怀特。我儿子笑得太厉害了。你知道在“冲突解决”那一集，当迈克尔读出德怀特所有的投诉时，还有关于“我用电话砸自己的头”那件事。迈克尔说，那怎么会是吉姆的错？然后吉姆解释了硬币、加重的耳机。
That put my son on the floor. And that is my favorite prank. So it's so fun to share it with them. And I cannot wait for them to see this scene. I forgot how many little extra, like, quips that Steve threw in. Like, see ya. Yeah, exactly. He's out of here. Look at the end. It's great.
那让我儿子笑得倒在地上。那是我最喜欢的恶作剧。所以和他们分享这些太有趣了。我迫不及待想让他们看到这一幕。我忘了史蒂夫加了多少额外的小俏皮话。比如，再见。是的，没错。他要走了。看最后。太棒了。
All right, everyone, here is your second drink of Goodbye Toby, part two. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
好了，各位，这是你们的《再见托比》第二部分的第二杯。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你们的独家幕后故事。
We're the office ladies. All right, everybody, we are still saying goodbye to Toby. It is Goodbye Toby, Part 2. It's a long goodbye, but he deserves it. He's been at the company a long time. He deserves a two-parter. Michael's going to give him a big send-off, lady. He sure is.
我们是办公室女士。好了，各位，我们还在和托比说再见。这是《再见托比》第二部分。这是一个漫长的告别，但他值得。他在公司待了很久。他值得一个两集篇幅的告别。迈克尔要给他一个盛大的欢送，女士。他确实会。
Guys, it's Season 4, Episode 19, written by Jen Salata and Paul Lieberstein, directed by Paul Figue. Here is a summary of part two of goodbye Toby. Okay. An extravagant goodbye party is being thrown in the parking lot for Toby. Ryan is arrested for fraud. Michael discovers big news about Jan. Jim plans to propose to Pam but gets upstaged by Andy and Phyllis discovers a secret. Does she ever? All right, jumping right in, fast fact number one. I'm calling this party time. Are you going to give me a breakdown of all the party?
伙计们，这是第四季第19集，由简·萨拉塔和保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，保罗·费格执导。这是《再见托比》第二部分的摘要。好的。停车场正在为托比举办一场奢华的告别派对。瑞安因欺诈被捕。迈克尔发现了关于简的重大新闻。吉姆计划向帕姆求婚，但被安迪抢了风头，菲利斯发现了一个秘密。她发现过吗？好了，直接进入，第一个速记事实。我称之为派对时间。你要给我分析一下所有的派对吗？
You know I am. We got fan questions from Abby M and Yvette M. How many days did it take to film Toby's Goodbye Party? How long did it take to set it up? Well, you know I went to Kentopedia. He said it took one full day to set it up and two days and nights to film. We filmed April 17th and 18th of 2008.
你知道我会的。我们收到了艾比·M和伊薇特·M的粉丝提问。拍摄托比的告别派对花了多少天？布置它花了多久？嗯，你知道我去了“肯特百科”。他说布置花了一整天，拍摄花了两个昼夜。我们是在2008年4月17日和18日拍摄的。
The Ferris wheel came from a company called Awesome Events, and it cost us $7,500 to rent that Ferris wheel for three days. Dang. That's a pricey Ferris wheel. Here's what I remember about those party scenes, Angela. It was very hot during the day, and then at night it got cold. Yeah.
摩天轮来自一家叫“Awesome Events”的公司，租用那个摩天轮三天花了我们7500美元。天哪。那是个昂贵的摩天轮。安吉拉，关于那些派对场景，我记得的是：白天非常热，到了晚上又变冷了。是的。
I remember I had hand warmers in my pockets at night, and you know when you go skiing and you put those toe warmers in your ski boots, I had those in my shoes for the night shoot. Also, whenever they didn't see our feet, we had ugs on, and Jenna, I have an ugg catch later in this episode. Whose ugs do you see? Not going to tell. Guys, you're going to have to wait for it.
我记得晚上我的口袋里有暖手宝，你知道当你去滑雪时，你会把那些暖脚贴放进滑雪靴里，我那天晚上的拍摄就是把它们放在鞋子里。另外，每当他们看不到我们的脚时，我们都穿着UGG雪地靴，珍娜，我这一集后面有一个关于UGG的发现。你看到了谁的UGG？我不告诉你。伙计们，你们得等着看。
She's making you wait for it. Also, in between takes, do you remember our wardrobe department had these big, puffy coats, like the kind that go down to your ankles, giant puffy coats, and they would bring them out to us so that we could put them on in between takes outside when we were cold. And you know what? What? I still have mine. You do?
她在让你们等着看。另外，在拍摄间隙，你还记得我们的服装部门有这些巨大的蓬松外套吗，就是那种长到脚踝的巨大蓬松外套，他们会拿出来给我们，这样我们在外面冷的时候可以在拍摄间隙穿上。你知道吗？什么？我还有我的那件。你有？
Oh, what a score. Yeah. And on the label, on the inside of the coat, it says, Pam written in Sharpie. Aw. Because that's how they knew whose coat belonged to who. They sharpied it.
哦，真是赚到了。是的。在外套内侧的标签上，用记号笔写着“帕姆”。啊。因为他们就是这样知道谁的外套属于谁的。他们用记号笔写的。
Well, these were like giant sleeping bags. Yes. Made into jackets. Well described. Okay, fast fact number two. I'm kind of sad. I know. This is not just goodbye toby.
好吧，这些就像巨大的睡袋。是的。做成了夹克。描述得很好。好的，第二个速记事实。我有点难过。我知道。这不仅仅是《再见托比》。
Nope. This is goodbye Kentapedia. Yes. Kent Sabornack. This was the end of his run on the office. Yeah. After this, he moved on and he became the producer and production manager for anger management, dear white people, and most recently the Connors.
不。这是《再见肯特百科》。是的。肯特·萨博纳克。这是他在《办公室》工作的终点。是的。在那之后，他继续前进，成为了《愤怒管理》、《亲爱的白人》以及最近的《康纳一家》的制片人和制作经理。
He is an amazing, amazing production manager, you guys. We were so lucky to have him for four seasons. And office ladies has been so lucky that he saved, like everything. Talk about digital hoarder. Kentapedia is giving you a run for your money. Well, I think he's beat me, but I just love him. And we loved him so much. Jenna, in anticipation of this being his last episode, I went through and found all of these emails during this week that I traded with Kent. This was like towards the end of my pregnancy. And he and I were having to schedule a lot of things around my OBGYN appointments and everything. And if I could share anything with you guys is the kindness and the thoughtfulness that this man had for every. every member of the cast and making the show the best it could be. And we were so sad to see him go.
他是一位了不起的制作经理，伙计们。我们很幸运能拥有他四个季度。而“办公室女士”很幸运，他保存了所有东西。谈谈数字囤积者。肯特百科让你赚了不少钱。嗯，我想他打败了我，但我就是喜欢他。我们非常爱他。珍娜，预料到这是他的最后一集，我翻找并找到了这一周我和肯特交换的所有这些电子邮件。这大概是在我怀孕快结束的时候。他和我要围绕我的妇产科预约和所有事情安排很多事情。如果我能和你们分享什么，那就是这个男人对每一位演员的善良和体贴，以及他让这部剧变得最好的努力。我们很难过看到他离开。
I just love this guy. I love him too. And I love being in touch with him. And he was so great to us on the office. And he's been so great to us on office ladies. We love you Kentapedia. We love you Kentapedia. And I'm going to share a few of our emails later in this episode.
我就是喜欢这个家伙。我也喜欢他。我喜欢和他保持联系。他在《办公室》里对我们太好了。他在“办公室女士”里也对我们太好了。我们爱你，肯特百科。我们爱你，肯特百科。我会在这一集后面分享我们的一些邮件。
Angela, I want to share one of my favorite fun facts about Kent as we say goodbye to him. Okay, what? In his youth, Kent was an assistant to the creator of Golden Girls. Her name is Susan Harris. And she loved Kent's last name so much that when she wrote Golden Girls, she named B. Arthur's character, Dorothy Zabornak. Amazing! Yes, he was the inspiration behind that name. He told me he was beyond excited by this honor.
安吉拉，在我们向肯特告别时，我想分享一个关于他最喜欢的趣事。好的，什么？在年轻时，肯特曾是《黄金女郎》创作者的助理。她的名字叫苏珊·哈里斯。她非常喜欢肯特的姓氏，以至于她在写《黄金女郎》时，给碧·亚瑟的角色取名为多萝西·扎博纳克。太神奇了！是的，他就是那个名字背后的灵感来源。他告诉我，他对比这个荣誉感到无比兴奋。
He was like, I mean, who wouldn't be? And then he went on to be the first assistant director on Golden Girls, and he said B. Arthur was like a second mother to him. He just loved her. That is so wonderful. I love all of that. We love you, Kent. Okay, rounding out my fast facts, fast fact number three, Angela, you came up with this idea, and I just loved it. I think we should do it for every character.
他说，我的意思是，谁不会呢？然后他继续担任《黄金女郎》的第一助理导演，他说碧·亚瑟对他来说就像第二个母亲。他就是爱她。这太美好了。我喜欢这一切。我们爱你，肯特。好的，完成我的速记事实，第三个速记事实，安吉拉，你提出了这个想法，我非常喜欢。我觉得我们应该为每个角色都这样做。
And now I'm like, oh, we might have missed a few. we might have to, in a revisited, do this for other characters. That's right. Here's what we're talking about. Angela said, whenever we say goodbye to a character, we should give them a show Bible goodbye. So I went through the show Bible and I gathered facts about Toby Flunderson. Yay! Here they are.
现在我在想，哦，我们可能漏掉了一些。我们可能不得不在重温时为其他角色做这件事。没错。这就是我们要说的。安吉拉说，每当我们向一个角色告别时，我们都应该给他们一个“剧本圣经告别”。所以我翻阅了剧本圣经，收集了关于托比·弗伦德森的事实。耶！它们在这里。
Toby Flinderson, graduate of Bishop O'Hara High School, class of 89. He is divorced, but his wife. is still his emergency contact, although her last name is Becker now. During his 12 years working HR at Dunder Mifflin, he has explained female anatomy to Dwight, told Kevin he should ditch Dunder Mifflin's health care plan and get on his fiance, Stacey's plan instead because it's definitely going to be better. He sent out a memo regarding Jim and Pam's PDA, and he attended Jan's deposition and was present for the reading of Michael's diary.
托比·弗伦德森，主教奥哈拉高中毕业生，89届。他离婚了，但他的前妻仍然是他的紧急联系人，尽管她现在的姓氏是贝克。在他为邓德·米夫林工作HR的12年里，他向德怀特解释过女性解剖结构，告诉凯文他应该放弃邓德·米夫林的医疗计划，转而加入他未婚妻斯泰西的计划，因为那肯定会更好。他发过一份关于吉姆和帕姆公开秀恩爱的备忘录，他参加了简的取证，并出席了迈克尔日记的宣读。
Toby is one of the founding members of the Finer Things Club. He bought Angela her baby jazz poster, and he can run a mile in seven minutes. He's been trying to flirt with Pam and ask her out ever since season three. That is also how long he's been talking about going to Costa Rica. He started talking about that ever since he heard the Scranton branch might be closing. And now, after a very awkward moment of rubbing Pam's knee, he is finally leaving. although guys he is going to come back spoiler alert oh i love that i love the show bible goodbye show bible goodbye it's like a show bible eulogy mm-hmm a little bit well we'll definitely have to do that for a few
托比是“精致事物俱乐部”的创始成员之一。他给安吉拉买了她的婴儿爵士海报，他能在七分钟内跑完一英里。从第三季开始，他就一直试图和帕姆调情并约她出去。这也是他谈论去哥斯达黎加的时间长度。自从他听说斯克兰顿分部可能要关闭以来，他就开始谈论这件事了。现在，在摸了帕姆膝盖的尴尬时刻之后，他终于要离开了。尽管伙计们，他会回来的，剧透预警。哦，我喜欢那个，我喜欢“剧本圣经告别”。剧本圣经告别，就像剧本圣经悼词。嗯，有点像。好吧，我们肯定得为几个角色做这件事。
characters in a revisited like for karen philippelli oh yeah that's got to be in a revisited we'll do it that is all i have angela quick fast facts today i like it i have some fun stuff from the shooting draft But maybe before we get into this episode, we should take a little break. Let's take a little break, but I've got a lot to say about this one. So we might be short here up on top, but we're going to be long later. That's what she said? Is that a thing she said? Maybe.
在重温中，比如凯伦·菲利佩利。哦，是的，那必须在重温中。我们会做的。这就是我所有的内容了，安吉拉，今天的速记事实很快。我喜欢它。我有一些来自拍摄草稿的有趣内容。但也许在我们进入这一集之前，我们应该休息一下。让我们休息一下，但我对这一集有很多话要说。所以我们现在可能说得短一点，但后面会很长。那是她说的吗？那是她说过的话吗？也许吧。
Maybe. I don't know. You decide over the break. Okay. All right. We are back. And Michael is so excited to have his moment. It is time for Toby's exit interview.
也许吧。我不知道。你们在休息期间决定吧。好的。好了。我们回来了。迈克尔非常兴奋能有属于他的时刻。是时候进行托比的离职面谈了。
Michael shows up with a gift. It's wrapped. There's a ribbon. Yeah, he walks in the conference room with Toby. He shuts the door. He's ready to get started, but then what happens? He says this. Can I just say that of all the idiots, in all the idiot villages, in all the idiot worlds,
迈克尔带着礼物出现了。它被包装好了。还有丝带。是的，他带着托比走进会议室。他关上门。他准备开始了，但接下来发生了什么？他说这个。我能说吗，在所有的白痴中，在所有的白痴村庄里，在所有的白痴世界里，
you stand alone, my friend. And then right as he's about to really go off, Holly enters. And he's like, oh, uh-oh. Hey, uh, and she's like, yeah, I've got to be here. This is part of my job. And he's like, no, no, no, shouldn't you just tour some more? Go see the bailer. She goes, maybe later. This is actually part of my job. And then Pam walks in. She's like, do you need me to take notes? Toby's all over it. Toby's like, stay. Pam, stay. She's like, all right. Well, this is now not going as Michael had planned. He gets out his note cards. He's written some questions. Again, Steve Correll should have won 15 Emmys. I mean, come. Come on. Yeah. This is his, of having all this stuff he wanted to just tee off on Toby about and now having to dial it back and somehow be acceptable in front of this woman he's falling in love with.
你是最孤独的一个，我的朋友。就在他准备真正发火时，霍莉进来了。他说，哦，呃，嘿，她说，是的，我必须在这里。这是我工作的一部分。他说，不，不，不，你不应该再去参观一下吗？去看看保释官。她说，也许晚点。这确实是我工作的一部分。然后帕姆进来了。她说，你需要我做记录吗？托比对此很上心。托比说，留下来。帕姆，留下来。她说，好吧。好吧，这现在没有按迈克尔计划的那样进行。他拿出他的笔记卡。他写了一些问题。再说一次，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔应该赢得15座艾美奖。我的意思是，拜托。拜托。是的。这是他拥有的，他想对托比发泄的所有事情，现在却不得不收敛，并以某种方式在让他坠入爱河的这个女人面前表现得可以接受。
Every moment, Steve crushes. His first question is, who do you think you are? And Toby goes, I'm Toby. Now, I hope you noticed in the background, I'm going to toot my own horn. I am taking notes. No, I know. I watched you write it all down. And I am actually writing down, who are you?
每一个时刻，史蒂夫都表现得淋漓尽致。他的第一个问题是，你以为你是谁？托比说，我是托比。现在，我希望你们注意到背景里，我要自吹自擂一下。我在做记录。不，我知道。我看着你把它都写下来了。我实际上写下了，你是谁？
And then I wrote down Toby. And a couple times I wrote down, he is Toby. But my whole backstory, and Angela, I loved doing these scenes. I loved every time Pam's sole purpose in a scene was to take notes. Because I was just an audience member. I got to just sit there. I didn't have any real lines I had to say or anything I had to do. You just had to try not to laugh.
然后我写下了托比。有好几次我写下了，他是托比。但我的整个背景故事，安吉拉，我喜欢做这些场景。我喜欢帕姆在场景中的唯一目的就是做记录的每一次。因为我只是一个观众。我只需要坐在那里。我没有任何真正的台词要说，也没有任何要做的事情。你只需要努力不笑出来。
Pretty much. But I always took diligent notes. I really did because I liked to pretend that Michael would ask me to transcribe these meetings later. I like to think he made you go in his office and read the whole thing back to him. Just so he could feel important. This was like something he saw in an old movie once that secretaries do for their bosses. That's right. His second note card says, what gives you the right?
差不多。但我总是做认真的记录。我真的做了，因为我喜欢假装迈克尔会让我以后转录这些会议。我喜欢认为他让你去他的办公室，把整件事读给他听。只是为了让他感到重要。这就像他曾经在老电影里看到秘书为老板做的事情。没错。他的第二张笔记卡写着，是什么给了你权利？
And this is when Holly steps in. She's like, you know what? I brought the binder. Do you want to use it? Take a look at it. Yeah. And Michael starts to ask Toby if he has any suggestions on ways that, you know, Dunder Mifflin could improve itself.
这就是霍莉介入的时候。她说，你知道吗？我带了活页夹。你想用它吗？看一看。是的。迈克尔开始问托比是否有任何关于邓德·米夫林可以如何改进的建议。
And Toby seems like he's going to answer this question until, oh my God, Steve puts his hands up to his face to shield himself from Holly. And he gives Toby this look. it's so good. He actually mouths the words, I'll kill you. Is that what he's saying? I missed it. Yeah. He says, I'll kill you. And in the script, it's written that he does the slit the throat, you know, the finger across the throat. Gesture. Yeah. But I don't know if this was Steve improvising. I feel like he probably gave them a few different choices, but the one they picked was him whispering. I'll kill you. It's so amazing.
托比看起来要回答这个问题，直到，天哪，史蒂夫把手举到脸上来遮挡自己不看霍莉。他给了托比一个眼神。太棒了。他实际上口型说了“我要杀了你”。那是他说的吗？我错过了。是的。他说，“我要杀了你”。在剧本里，写着他做了割喉的动作，你知道，手指划过喉咙。手势。是的。但我不知道这是不是史蒂夫即兴发挥的。我觉得他可能给了他们几种不同的选择，但他们选中的是他低声说，“我要杀了你”。太神奇了。
And Toby just goes, I guess everything's okay. Yeah. And he's like, you know, he has this moment where he's like, I mean, I made it this far. Why not? Well, Pam is going to suggest that Toby opened his gift. Toby open it. What is it? And Michael's like, no, no, no, no, no.
托比只是说，我想一切都还好。是的。他有那种时刻，他就像，我的意思是，我走到这一步了。为什么不呢？好吧，帕姆建议托比打开他的礼物。托比打开它。是什么？迈克尔说，不，不，不，不，不。
You know what? You guys, it's a rock with a note on it that says suck on this. I watched this episode with Lee. He laughed so hard at this. joke. He couldn't stop laughing that it was a rock. He just thought that was so funny. Michael, you know, acts like he had no idea and he's like, who pulled this prank on Toby? This is horrible. And Dwight's like, you told me to do it. And he's like, shh. And then he goes, you know what this was? It was a psych. Siked you out. Because there's a real gift coming. And this is my second favorite
你知道吗？伙计们，那是一块上面写着“吸这个”的石头。我和李一起看了这一集。他被这个笑话逗得大笑。他笑得停不下来，因为那是一块石头。他觉得那太搞笑了。迈克尔，你知道，表现得好像他完全不知道，他说，是谁对托比开了这个恶作剧？这太可怕了。德怀特说，你让我做的。他说，嘘。然后他说，你知道这是什么吗？这是一个心理战。戏弄你。因为真正的礼物还在后面。这是我作为帕姆第二喜欢的事情，
thing to do as Pam, after taking notes in a meeting, which is painting Michael into a corner. And she says, what's the gift, Michael? What is it? Oh, is it your watch? And he's like, it is. It is my watch. How did you know? And she says, I just knew. He's so ticked off. He has to give Toby his watch. You know what? That's a genuine Seiko piece. He's going to have to give Toby the certificate that's framed as well, I guess. I guess he will. This delightful scene is interrupted by some hubbub in the bullpen. Everyone is gathered around Jim's computer watching a YouTube video. Yeah.
在会议中做记录之后，那就是把迈克尔逼入绝境。她说，礼物是什么，迈克尔？是什么？哦，是你的手表吗？他说，是的。是我的手表。你怎么知道的？她说，我就是知道。他气坏了。他不得不把他的手表给托比。你知道吗？那是一块真正的精工表。我想他还得把装裱好的证书给托比。我想他会给的。这个令人愉快的场景被大厅里的一些喧闹声打断了。每个人都围在吉姆的电脑旁看YouTube视频。是的。
Ryan is being arrested and someone has uploaded the moment and they're all watching it. I want you guys to know that they actually put that video on YouTube. It was a private account. So John is actually watching it during that scene. We all are. But it was a private account. When the episode aired, they made. the video go live on YouTube so everyone could watch it. Oh, that's so great. I didn't know that. Yeah.
瑞安被捕了，有人上传了那一刻，他们都在看。我想让你们知道，他们实际上把那个视频放到了YouTube上。那是一个私人账户。所以约翰在那个场景中实际上是在看它。我们都在看。但那是一个私人账户。当这一集播出时，他们让视频在YouTube上上线，这样每个人都可以看。哦，那太棒了。我不知道。是的。
But Michael is very upset. He's in his office and Holly is saying to Toby, what are you doing this situation? Toby says, I don't do anything. Just leave it alone. But Holly is amazing. She goes into Michael's office and she really comforts him. Michael is crying. He's really sweet. He says, I'm worried about my friend. Yeah, and she says, that's normal. You take the time you need. to have your feelings. Which leads to just a wonderful talking head, Angela, that I love, where Michael says, Holly is sweet and simple like a lady baker. And he just wouldn't be surprised to find out that she'd worked in a bakery before coming
但迈克尔非常难过。他在办公室里，霍莉对托比说，你在这个情况下在做什么？托比说，我什么都不做。随它去吧。但霍莉太棒了。她走进迈克尔的办公室，真的安慰了他。迈克尔在哭。他真的很甜。他说，我担心我的朋友。是的，她说，那是正常的。你花点时间去感受你的情绪。这导致了一个美妙的采访片段，安吉拉，我喜欢，迈克尔说，霍莉像一位女士烘焙师一样甜美简单。他一点也不惊讶发现她在来到邓德·米夫林之前曾在面包店工作过。
to Dunder Mifflin. I mean, he's pretty sure she's baked on a professional level. Because baking is love, right? Yeah, only sweet ladies bake. Sweet ladies who take care of you. Yeah. Aw. Well, after this very very...
我的意思是，他很确定她在专业水平上烘焙过。因为烘焙就是爱，对吧？是的，只有甜美的女士才会烘焙。照顾你的甜美女士。是的。啊。好吧，在迈克尔这个非常非常……
sweet Michael talking head. We're all going to go out in the parking lot because the party is starting. Oh yeah. But before we get into that parking lot, Jenna, I need to share a little backstory. Okay. Have you ever been on the phone with someone and you actually hear that person go into a full flop sweat? Where is this going? Because I have. Okay. I have. And that person was Kent Zabornack. Oh my gosh. Oh gosh. Not only did I remember this, but then I found some emails between Kent and I that really painted the picture. And I wanted to share the story with you guys that I almost didn't make it to the parking lot. Oh, now I know what you're talking about. In my emails, I found that on Thursday, April 10th of 2008 at 4 p.m. I had a routine checkup with my OBGYN. I emailed Kent about it. He said, no problem, Angie. We'll have you wrapped in time to make it to that doctor's appointment. So, lady, while I was at my mom, doctor's appointment, you know, how they sort of check all your vitals and do everything. And I had had, like, I was feeling like a little bit of cramping, but nothing I was really worried about. And she was like, Angela, you're having contractions. And I said, what? And she said, yeah. And she immediately
甜美的采访片段之后。我们都要去停车场，因为派对要开始了。哦，是的。但在我们进入那个停车场之前，珍娜，我需要分享一点背景故事。好的。你有没有和某人通过电话，然后你真的听到那个人开始大汗淋漓？这要往哪儿去？因为我有。好的。我有。那个人就是肯特·萨博纳克。天哪。哦，天哪。我不仅记得这件事，我还发现了一些肯特和我之间的邮件，真的描绘了当时的画面。我想和你们分享这个故事，我差点没能去成停车场。哦，现在我知道你在说什么了。在我的邮件里，我发现2008年4月10日星期四下午4点。我有一个妇产科的例行检查。我给肯特发了邮件。他说，没问题，安吉。我们会让你及时结束工作去参加那个医生的预约。所以，女士，当我在我医生的预约时，你知道，他们检查你所有的生命体征并做所有事情。我当时感觉有点像抽筋，但我并没有真正担心。她说，安吉拉，你在宫缩。我说，什么？她说，是的。她立刻
sent me to the hospital from your doctor's appointment. From my doctor's appointment at four o'clock, now I'm in the hospital. I'm having contractions every five minutes. And around six o'clock in the evening, Jenny O'Keefe, who is our second AD, called me to tell me my call time, right? For the next day. For the next day. She's like, hi, Angela, your call time tomorrow is 5.30 a.m. And I said, Jenny, I'm in the hospital. She said, what? And I said, I'm having contractions. And she goes, okay, okay, I will get back to you. Literally three seconds later, my phone rings, and it's Kent Sabornag. And I will never forget the first thing he said to me. He said, hey, hey, Anch, we having this baby today?
从你的医生预约那里把我送到了医院。从我四点钟的医生预约，现在我在医院。我每五分钟宫缩一次。大约晚上六点，我们的第二助理导演珍妮·奥基夫打电话告诉我我的通告时间，对吧？第二天。第二天。她说，嗨，安吉拉，你明天的通告时间是早上5点30分。我说，珍妮，我在医院。她说，什么？我说，我在宫缩。她说，好的，好的，我会再联系你。字面上三秒钟后，我的电话响了，是肯特·萨博纳克。我永远不会忘记他对我说的第一句话。他说，嘿，嘿，安吉，我们今天生这个孩子吗？
But like his voice cracked and went up. It's like, we having this baby today? Because what you guys have to know is they were building a freaking Ferris wheel in the parking lot. That's right. And to give you guys some context, this was all happening about three weeks before your due date, right? Yeah. We just had a few more days of filming with you. Everyone just assumed that we would finish this episode and then you would go off on your
但他的声音变调了，变高了。就像，我们今天生这个孩子吗？因为你们必须知道的是，他们正在停车场搭建一个该死的摩天轮。没错。给你们一些背景信息，这一切发生在你预产期前大约三周，对吧？是的。我们和你还有几天的拍摄。每个人都以为我们会拍完这一集，然后你就会去度暑假，生你的孩子。肯特以为他有时间。但实际上，你在医院，他可能正站在停车场，看着他们组装这个摩天轮，他快疯了。是的。如果安吉拉不能去，安迪怎么求婚？是的。在摩天轮前面。
summer hiatus and have your baby. Kit thought he had time. But in reality, you are in the hospital, and he was probably standing in the parking lot as they're assembling this Ferris wheel, and he's freaking out. Yeah. How does Andy propose if Angela can't be there? Yeah. In front of the Ferris wheel.
所以我说，肯特，我不知道。我不知道我今晚是不是要生这个孩子。他说，好吧，你会随时通知我吗？我说，当然。结果是假性宫缩。我在那里待到凌晨两点左右。第二天我确实不得不去工作了半天。让我告诉你，肯特已经雇了一个特技演员。
So I said, Kent, I don't know. I don't know if I'm having this baby tonight. And he said, well, would you keep me posted? And I said, sure. and it turned out to be false labor. I was there till about two in the morning. I did have to go work a half day the next day. And let me tell you, Kent had already hired a stunt woman.
她的名字叫梅丽莎·巴克。她将成为我余下拍摄的替身。他们真的想确保如果我没有台词场景，我就不必工作。对吧？他们会用梅丽莎。安吉拉，在片场有她真是太奇怪了，因为她穿得和你一模一样。她做的发型和你一模一样。从后面看，她看起来真的很像你。
Her name was Melissa Barker. And she was to be my body double for the rest of this shoot. They really wanted to try to make sure I did not have to work if I was not in a speaking scene. Right? They would use Melissa. Angela, it was so weird to have her on set because she was dressed just like you. She had her hair done just like you. From behind, she seriously looked like you.
所以是的，如果会议室里有一个场景，而你没有说话，她就会坐在那里，我会忘记她不是你。好吧，听着，这一切都发生在周四晚上。到周六，肯特给全体演员发了这封邮件，4月12日星期六。嘿，伙计们，我们的单行日程表明天晚些时候会出来。请注意，我们正试图在下周拍完安吉拉·金赛小姐的戏份，这样她就可以在生下她的小女儿之前好好休息一周。为了适应这一点，周三到周五的日程安排将比平时更艰苦，
So yes, if there was a scene in the conference room and you were just not speaking, she would be sitting there and I would forget that she wasn't you. Well, listen, this all happened on a Thursday night. By Saturday, Kent sent the whole cast this email, Saturday, April 12th. Hey, you guys, our one-liner schedule will be coming out later tomorrow. please be advised that we are trying to shoot Miss Angela Kinsey out next week so she can go rest easily for a full week before delivering her little girl. And to accommodate this, Wednesday through Friday's schedule will be more grueling than normal,
特别是周五晚上的工作。想想摩天轮和烟花。我们都会采取额外的预防措施，确保安吉拉舒适，并确保她在这里的每一刻都保持水分。所以准备好对讲机的聊天吧。安吉拉又10-1了。所以，是的，我差点没能去成停车场。好吧，我很高兴你去了。
especially Friday night's work. Think Ferris wheel and fireworks. We will all take extra precautions to ensure Angela is comfortable and that she remains hydrated every single moment she is here. So prepare for the walkie-talkie chatter. Angela's going 10-1 again. So, yeah, I almost didn't make it to the parking lot. Well, I'm glad you made it.
我也很高兴。我确实记得全体演员和工作人员都有点担心。我们很关心。我们想确保我们先完成你的工作，这样你就可以离开。是的，我离开了，梅丽莎·巴克留下了。所以谢谢你，梅丽莎·巴克。女士，现在每个人都在离开大楼去停车场，25分52秒，
I am too. I do remember the whole cast and crew were a little worried. We were concerned. We wanted to make sure that we got your work done first so that you could leave. Yes, and I left and Melissa Barker stayed. So thank you, Melissa Barker. And lady, now everyone is exiting the building going into the parking lot, 25 minutes, 52 seconds,
UGG警报。谁穿了UGG？谁穿了温暖、毛茸茸的UGG？这个人是谁？是我。这开启了这一集的一个主题，他们对我放弃了。他们就像，让她舒服就行了。我觉得在几乎每一个镜头里你都能看到我的肚子，
Ug alert. Who has theugs? Who has the warm, fuzzy hugs on? Who is this person? It is me. And this starts a theme for this episode where they just gave up with me. They were like, just keep her comfortable. And I feel like in almost every shot you can see my belly,
我穿着UGG，没人关心。你知道吗？我记得看《宋飞正传》时，朱莉娅·路易斯-德瑞弗斯怀孕了。有几次我觉得是一样的。他们就像，你知道吗，我们都知道她怀孕了。我们假装她没怀孕，因为她的角色没怀孕。让我们一起面对吧，伙计们。是的，我们只是放弃了。没错。好吧，迈克尔对没有反重力机器感到非常失望，但他对摩天轮印象深刻。是的，还有一个充气城堡，顺便说一句，
and I'm wearingugs, and no one cares. You know what? I remember watching Seinfeld when Julia Louis Dreyfus, was pregnant. And there were a few times where I feel like it was the same. They were like, you know what, we all know she's pregnant. We're pretending like she's not pregnant because her character's not pregnant. Let's just, we're all in it together, folks. Yeah, we're just giving up. Exactly. Well, Michael is very disappointed that there is not an anti-gravity machine, but he is impressed with the Ferris wheel. Yeah, and there's a bouncy house, which, by the way,
可怜的布莱恩在高温下不得不一次又一次地在里面跳上跳下，里面太热了，还有他跳啊跳的删减片段，甚至没能放进这一集里。我知道。这也是帕姆注意到烟花的时候，她意识到，天哪，吉姆今晚要求婚吗？她太兴奋了。女士，我觉得你在这一集里表现得太好了。我觉得你的表演非常细腻，情感非常到位。我觉得这是一份美丽、美丽的工作。天哪。非常感谢。是的。我们收到了索菲·F的粉丝提问。你在不拍摄的时候能去玩游乐设施吗？不能。出于保险目的，他们不会让没有剧本要求上摩天轮的演员上摩天轮。
poor Brian in the heat had to jump up and down in over and over and it was so hot in there and there's deleted scenes of him jumping and jumping and it didn't even make it in the episode. I know. This is also when Pam clocks the fireworks and she realizes, oh my gosh, is Jim going to propose tonight? She's so excited. Lady, I thought you were so good in this episode. I thought your performance was so subtle and the emotion was so there. I just thought it was a beautiful, beautiful job. Oh my gosh. Thank you so much. Yeah. We had a fan question from Sophie F. Did you get to go on the rides while you weren't filming? No. For insurance purposes, they were not going to let cast members who were not scripted to be on the Ferris wheel get on the Ferris wheel.
他们想让我离那个东西远点。他们就像，嘿，大肚子孕妇，你已经让这事够乱了。离远点。我记得和简·萨拉塔谈过这件事。她说，天哪，所有的编剧都非常兴奋。他们说，我们要去坐摩天轮。那会很有趣。然后他们谁也没坐。不。我记得他们有充气城堡的时候。
They wanted me nowhere near that thing. They were like, hey, big pregnant lady, you're already freaking this out. Stay away. I remember talking to Jen Salada about it. And she said, Oh, my gosh, all the writers were like so excited. They're like, we're going to ride the Ferris wheel. It's going to be so fun. And then none of them ever wrote it. No. I remember when they had the bouncy houses.
每当我们有充气城堡时，你知道，总会有人说，哦，孩子们今天能过来吗？他们说，不行。嗯。没人能上那些东西。好吧，两个被允许上摩天轮的人，我记得他们拍这个的时候，安吉拉，这些可怜的家伙。你知道他们不得不绕那个摩天轮转了多少次吗？作为一个坐了12小时侏罗纪公园游乐设施的人，你知道那有多老套。
Whenever we had a bouncy house, you know, there'd be someone to be like, oh, could the kids come by today? They're like, nope. Mm-hmm. No one get on those things. Well, two people who were allowed to get on the Ferris wheel, I remember when they shot this, Angela, these poor guys. Do you know how many times they had to go around that Ferris wheel? Just as a person who rode the Jurassic Park ride for 12 hours, you know how old it gets.
这对你来说是个触发点。是个触发点。我看着他们坐那个摩天轮坐了一个小时。我不明白他们怎么没完全吐出来。当你观看这一集时，你会看到迈克尔和霍莉在摩天轮上的一个场景，但还有更多。它们在删减片段里。它们真的很可爱。所以他们在里面待了一会儿。
It's a trigger for you. It's a trigger. And I watched them ride that Ferris wheel for about an hour. I don't understand how they weren't completely sick. When you watch the episode, you see one scene between Michael and Holly on the Ferris wheel, but they're more. And they're in the deleted scenes. And they're really cute. So they were in there for a while.
是的，我记得。我喜欢的一个摩天轮场景是迈克尔在给霍莉讲故事。就在他们到达摩天轮顶部时，她摇晃了车厢。就像向前倾斜，让它摇晃。他说，哦，天哪。然后他们俩都开始笑了。他说，你抓到我了。你知道，这太可爱了。这就像迈克尔会做的事情。是的。那可能会惹恼任何人。是的。因为那是一件烦人的事。确实是。是的。他对此感到很高兴。太可爱了。好吧，当他们终于从摩天轮上下来时，霍莉抓到摩斯、德怀特和梅雷迪思在对她的车做些什么。你们在对我的车做什么？
Yeah, I remember that. One of the Ferris wheel scenes that I love is Michael is telling Holly a story. And right as they get to the top of the Ferris wheel, she shakes the car. like kind of leans forward so it rocks. And he goes, oh my God. And then they both start laughing. And he's like, you got me. You know, it's so cute. It's like something Michael would have done. Yes. That probably would annoy anyone else. Yeah. Because that's an annoying thing to do. It really is. Yeah. And he's delighted by it. So cute. Well, when they finally get off the Ferris wheel, Holly catches Moes, Dwight, and Meredith doing something to her car. What are you doing to my car?
好吧，他们做的是把一只浣熊放进去，因为他们还在欺负她。是的。你们可能很好奇，为什么梅雷迪思会参与德怀特和摩斯的欺负？我们在一个删减片段中了解到梅雷迪思不是霍莉的粉丝。你们能播放那个片段吗？我想那让我们成了邻居。就在几条街外。哦，也许你可以带我看看一些有趣的地方，或者去哪里做指甲。当然，那听起来很有趣。太棒了。我讨厌那个婊子。我想割开她的脸。它就这么突然冒出来了。
Well, what they're doing is putting a raccoon inside of it, because they're still hazing her. Yeah. And you guys might be curious, why is Meredith involved with Dwight and Moses hazing? We learn in a deleted scene that Meredith is not a fan of Holly. Can you guys play the clip? I think that makes us neighbors. It's a couple streets over. Oh, maybe you can show me some of the fun hangouts or where to get my nails done. Sure, that sounds fun. Great. I hate that bitch. I want to cut her face. It just comes out of nowhere.
霍莉说，嘿，我想我们是邻居。也许我们可以一起做些事。然后当她走开时，梅雷迪思立刻说，我讨厌那个婊子。德怀特听到了，他说，嗯哼，我有一个同谋。德怀特和梅雷迪思在计划所有这些不同的恶作剧时，有很多非常有趣的场景。它们很棒。它们在DVD上。我和凯特发了短信，因为在剧本里，有一些我想读给你们听的导演说明。
Holly is like, hey, I think we're neighbors. Maybe we could do stuff together. And then immediately as she walks away, Meredith is like, I hate that bitch. And Dwight overhears this, and he's like, uh-huh, I have an accomplice. And there's all these really fun scenes between Dwight and Meredith as they plan out all these different pranks. They're great. They're on the DVD. And I texted with Kate because in the script, there's some direction I want to read to.
它说，迈克尔带走霍莉。在背景里，德怀特随意地打开霍莉的车门，释放了獾。然后有一个星号，它说浣熊立刻攻击了梅雷迪思。所以我当时想，是獾还是浣熊？但无论如何，我给凯特发了短信，我说，你不得不拍摄被浣熊攻击的戏吗？简·萨拉塔说，剧本的原始大纲让他们在车里放了一只獾。哦！而不是浣熊。但他们找不到一只训练有素的獾来攻击梅雷迪思。好吧，谁知道呢？
you. It says, Michael leads Holly away. In the background, Dwight casually opens Holly's car door, releasing the badger. Then there's an asterix, and it says the raccoon instantly attacks Meredith. So I was like, is it a badger or is it a raccoon? But either way, I texted Kate, and I said, did you have to film getting attacked by a raccoon? Jen Salada said, the original outline for the script had them putting a badger in the car. Oh! Instead of a raccoon. But they couldn't find a trained badger to attack Meredith. Well, who knew?
所以肯特从一个叫“电影动物”的地方找来了一只浣熊。但后来他们意识到，即使是浣熊也没有训练到足以进行攻击场景的程度，至少没有达到他们想让凯特身上有浣熊的程度。是的。所以他们雇了一个特技替身。来做这件事，但后来他们意识到最好的方法可能是用CGI。所以他们拍了一个凯特只是乱挥舞的镜头，好像她被浣熊攻击一样，但最后，整件事都被剪掉了。
So Kent got a raccoon from this place called Critters of the Cinema. But then they realized that even a raccoon is not really trained well enough for an attack scene, at least not to the point where they felt like they wanted Kate to have a raccoon on her. Yeah. So they hired a stunt double. to do it, but then they realized the best way to do it was maybe with CGI. So they did a shot of Kate just flailing around as if she was being attacked by a raccoon, but in the end, the whole thing got cut.
是的。然而，凯特说后来有一个场景，她的脸上确实有抓痕。是的。我给凯特发了短信，她说他们拍了她尖叫和跑来跑去的戏。然后他们最终没用任何片段。她说再一次，动物比我有更好的代表性。这太搞笑了。因为她总是被卷入这些动物攻击事件。
Yeah. However, Kate said that there is a scene later where she has scratch marks on her face. Yeah. I texted Kate and she said they filmed her screaming and running around. then they didn't end up using any of it. And she said once again, the animals have better representation than me. It's very funny. Because she always gets roped into these animal attacks.
我发现了一个迈克·舒尔作为摩斯谈论浣熊的旧采访。哦，是吗？这就是摩斯对此的说法。引用，我爱那只浣熊。浣熊的名字叫椅子，因为当我发现它时，它正在吃一把椅子。它有一个叫蹦床腿的兄弟。椅子非常好。我确保椅子安全到家了。
I found an old interview that Mike sure did as Moes talking about the raccoon. Oh, yeah? This is what Moes has to say about it. Quote, I love the raccoon. The raccoon's name is chair, because when I found him, he was eating a chair. He has a brother named trampoline leg. Chair is very nice. I made sure Chair got home safely.
椅子永远不会伤害任何人，除了有一次我喂它柠檬时，椅子咬了我的脸。引用结束。摩斯真是个健谈者。迈克尔真的站出来维护霍莉了，你知道吗？他告诉他们应该为自己感到羞耻，霍莉是自二战以来发生在这家公司最好的事情。她会非常感激，以至于她摸了迈克尔的手臂。并且在那里停留了一秒钟。一秒钟，我数了。
Chair would never hurt anyone except once chair bit my cheek when I was feeding him a lemon. End quote. Mo's the conversationalist. Michael really comes to Holly's defense, you know? He tells them they should be ashamed of themselves and that Holly is the best thing to happen to this company since World War II. And she is going to be so appreciative that she touches Michael's arm. and it kind of lingers there for a second. For a second, I counted.
九秒。数出来。一，二，三，四，五，六，七，八，九。拜托。那是一个停留的触摸。这个采访片段让我心碎。他太兴奋了。这太好了。
Nine seconds. Count that out. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine. Come on. That's a lingering touch right there. This talking head broke my heart. He's so excited. This is so good.
九秒。数一下。一，二，三，四，五，六，七，八，九。得了吧。那可是久久不愿离去的触碰。这个受访者让我心碎。他太兴奋了。这真是太棒了。
He says, did you see that? Did you see that? He's kind of talking to the documentarian crew, right? He's like, you know, Jan didn't believe in affection. So sometimes he just doesn't know how to react when a girl touches him, but he really likes it. Holly is so perfect for him. I know. But there's a problem at the party, Angela.
他说，你看到了吗？你看到了吗？他是在跟纪录片摄制组说话，对吧？他就像是说，你知道，简不相信感情。所以有时候当一个女孩碰他时，他不知道该怎么反应，但他其实很喜欢。霍莉对他来说太完美了。我知道。但在派对上出了个问题，安吉拉。
I'm sorry to tell you, the barbecue sauce is out. Oh, yeah. By the way, do you know who's doing the barbecuing? It's Gino and Leo from Vance Refrigeration, played by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg are two writers. They were perfect as those guys. I don't know if that's a compliment or not, but they were great as those two idiots. Well, Phyllis tells Kevin you need to go get more barbecue sauce. Well, guess what?
很抱歉告诉你，烧烤酱用完了。哦，对了。顺便问一下，你知道是谁在负责烧烤吗？是万斯制冷公司的吉诺和里奥，由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格饰演，他们是两位编剧。他们演这两个家伙真是绝了。我不知道这算不算夸奖，但他们演那两个白痴演得太棒了。好吧，菲利斯告诉凯文你需要去拿更多的烧烤酱。好吧，你猜怎么着？
There was a deleted scene where Angela's like, Phyllis, I got it. No problem. She's like, really? She's like, yeah, I'll get the barbecue sauce. Don't worry about it. And Phyllis is like, oh, okay. Thanks. And then Angela never goes and gets the barbecue sauce. And then Phyllis goes, hey, Angela, they really need the barbecue sauce. And I said, oh, oops, I forgot. Now you know what it's like to
有一个被删减的片段，安吉拉说，菲利斯，我拿到了。没问题。菲利斯说，真的吗？她说，是啊，我会去拿烧烤酱的。别担心。菲利斯就说，哦，好的。谢谢。然后安吉拉根本就没去拿烧烤酱。接着菲利斯说，嘿，安吉拉，他们真的很需要烧烤酱。我说，哦，哎呀，我忘了。现在你知道和那种无能的助理一起工作是什么感觉了。
work with someone who's an incompetent assistant. Phyllis is like so ticked. And that's when she goes to Kevin and says, Kevin, can you go get the barbecue sauce? So there's a lot of deleted Phyllis and Angela in this episode that really, really ratches up Phyllis's pissed offness towards Angela. You know what that is from Angela? That's some sandwich right there. Sabotage. Sabotage. Yeah. It's time for Michael's big speech. There can't really be a party without a speech for Michael, right? Mm-hmm. Except it's not just a speech. He's going to sing for us, guys. Oh, wait, wait. First of all, he makes a huge thank you to Phyllis for throwing the best party they've ever had at 29, 22 seconds. this might be the biggest Angela I roll of the whole entire series.
菲利斯气坏了。就在那时她去找凯文说，凯文，你能去拿烧烤酱吗？所以这一集里有很多被删减的菲利斯和安吉拉的戏份，真的大大加剧了菲利斯对安吉拉的愤怒。你知道安吉拉那是怎么回事吗？那简直就是一种破坏。蓄意破坏。是啊。现在是迈克尔发表重要演讲的时候了。没有迈克尔的演讲，派对就不算完整，对吧？嗯。只不过这不仅仅是演讲。伙计们，他要为我们唱歌。哦，等等，等等。首先，他在29分22秒时非常感谢菲利斯举办了他们有史以来最好的派对。这可能是整部剧里安吉拉翻白眼翻得最厉害的一次。
Yeah. It's a full body eye roll. Angela, I'm going to say something to you right now and you're just going to have to hear it. What? He's not wrong. This is the best party. It's the best party. Okay, fine.
是啊。那是全身心的翻白眼。安吉拉，我现在要对你说一句话，你必须听着。什么？他说得没错。这是最好的派对。这是最好的派对。好吧，行吧。
Outside of maybe casino night where I think maybe Michael hired, you know, a professional party committee or something. But for a homemade office party, Phyllis nailed it. It's great. She did. She nailed it. What you guys don't even know because it's in deleted scenes is there were corn dogs that made Stanley and Oscar happy. There were deep fried twinkies. I mean, there were all kinds of things happening here. And during this speech, thanking Phyllis, Michael is going to go on to say, hey, Toby, why don't you come up here? Give a farewell speech. Toby doesn't want to. Michael forces him to. It's a deleted scene. It's delicious. You got to hear Toby's farewell speech. Toby, Toby, Toby has written a fantastic speech for you. He spent a year on it. It's very funny and charming and heartwarming, and it rhymes. And if it's not any good, he has instructed us all to storm the stage and beat him to a bloody pulp.
除了赌场之夜，我觉得迈克尔可能雇了专业的派对委员会什么的。但对于办公室自办的派对来说，菲利斯做得太棒了。真的很棒。她做到了。她做得太完美了。你们甚至不知道的是，因为在删减片段里，还有让斯坦利和奥斯卡开心的玉米热狗。还有油炸甜甜圈。我是说，这里发生了各种各样的事情。在感谢菲利斯的演讲中，迈克尔接着说，嘿，托比，你为什么不上来？发表一下告别演讲。托比不想。迈克尔强迫他。这是一个删减片段。太精彩了。你一定要听听托比的告别演讲。托比，托比，托比为你写了一篇精彩的演讲稿。他花了一年时间准备。非常有趣、迷人且感人，而且还押韵。如果写得不好，他指示我们所有人冲上台把他打得头破血流。
So take it away, Toby. Okay, it's really great to be here tonight. The Paris wheel, band, the low sun light. I'm gonna miss you all when I go to Costa Rica, and if I keep drinking beer like this, I'm gonna have to take a leka. Like, on a more personal note, I just want to say thanks, no matter what was going on in my life,
所以，托比，开始吧。好的，今晚能在这里真的很高兴。摩天轮、乐队、低垂的夕阳。我要去哥斯达黎加了，我会想念你们所有人的，如果我继续这样喝啤酒，我就得去撒个尿了。呃，说点私人的，我只想说谢谢，无论我生活中发生了什么，
you know, my divorce or the custody battle or that thing with my sister. It was just nice knowing I had a supportive place to come to. Okay, play the cutoff, music. No. I'm gonna really miss going to beers with you guys every Tuesday night. Yeah! And lastly, I'd love to urge you to keep up with my fight to have the building checked for radon gas.
你知道，我的离婚、监护权之争，或者我妹妹那件事。能有一个支持我的地方真是太好了。好了，放切断音乐。不。我真的会很想念每周二晚上和你们一起去喝啤酒的时光。耶！最后，我强烈呼吁你们继续支持我，要求检查大楼里的氡气。
You know, it's a real serious matter. And every time I try to have it. Blah, blah, blah, blah. Overstain, you're welcome. Let's keep it moving. Let's keep it moving. Toby, everybody. Okay, Angela, I remember filming that.
你知道，这是一个非常严肃的问题。每次我试图……巴拉巴拉巴拉。好了，不用谢。我们继续吧。我们继续吧。托比，大家。好了，安吉拉，我记得拍摄那一段。
And I especially remember the part when he says how much he loved going out for beers with us every Tuesday night. And the look on Michael's face. Michael's like, wait, what? People go out for drinks every Tuesday. Yeah, Michael has clearly never been invited to beers on Tuesday. No. And then I love Toby's last thing with this plea about the radon. Yes, which is, by the way, going to play out all the way until season nine.
我特别记得他说他有多喜欢每周二晚上和我们一起出去喝啤酒的那部分。还有迈克尔脸上的表情。迈克尔心想，等等，什么？人们每周二都出去喝酒？是啊，迈克尔显然从来没被邀请去参加周二的啤酒聚会。没有。然后我喜欢托比关于氡气的最后请求。是的，顺便说一下，这件事一直持续到第九季。
I know. It's so good. So Michael is going to sing for Toby. He's going to sing a parody of Goodbye Stranger. called Goodbye Toby. We had a fan question from Stephanie, Claire, Yvette, and Ashley, who said, who wrote the amazing parody song, Goodbye Toby? Guys, Paul Lieberstein, Paul Lieberstein wrote the lyrics to his own character's goodbye parody
我知道。太棒了。所以迈克尔要为托比唱歌。他要唱一首《再见陌生人》的戏仿歌曲，叫《再见托比》。我们收到了斯蒂芬妮、克莱尔、伊薇特和阿什利的粉丝提问，他们问，是谁写了那首精彩的戏仿歌曲《再见托比》？伙计们，保罗·利伯斯坦，保罗·利伯斯坦为他自己角色的告别戏仿歌曲写了歌词。
song. But in this speech, Michael says, you guys know I'm an accomplished songwriter. Mm-hmm. So which Pam, under her breath, says, a parody songwriter. Yes. And he mentions two of the other songs he's famous for are beers in heaven and total eclipse of the fart. I went online and I found this old interview that Paul Lieberstein did where he revealed the lyrics for beers in heaven and total eclipse of the fart. And we might have done something with those lyrics. Angela, do you want to tell everybody? We did. When Jenna emailed our group here that she found the original lyrics, we got so tickled. So I asked my husband Josh, who was the acapella guy in college. Aka what? Oh, yeah.
但在演讲中，迈克尔说，你们知道我是个有成就的词曲作者。嗯。帕姆在下面小声说，是个戏仿词曲作者。是的。他还提到了他出名的另外两首歌是《天堂里的啤酒》和《屁之全蚀》。我上网找到了保罗·利伯斯坦的一篇旧采访，他在采访中透露了《天堂里的啤酒》和《屁之全蚀》的歌词。我们可能用这些歌词做了一些事情。安吉拉，你想告诉大家吗？我们做了。当珍娜给我们的群组发邮件说她找到了原始歌词时，我们觉得太搞笑了。所以我问了我的丈夫乔希，他在大学时是阿卡贝拉成员。也就是什么？哦，是的。
That was Josh. And Josh sings beers in heaven. You drank. You saw it in heaven. But it tastes the same. You drank a left your toe. I love it. That was just a little window into Josh's karaoke evenings.
那是乔希。乔希唱了《天堂里的啤酒》。你喝了。你在天堂里看到了。但味道是一样的。你喝了一口，留下了你的脚趾。我喜欢。这只是乔希卡拉OK之夜的一点缩影。
His voice is so good. He's really got a good voice. But bears in heaven, getting to really hear it in all of its beauty. I loved it. I laughed so hard. I loved every minute. And Jenna, one of the sound engineers at Earwolf, Jordan Duffy, is going to sing total eclipse of the fart.
他的声音真好。他确实有一副好嗓子。但《天堂里的啤酒》，能真正听到它所有的美感。我喜欢。我笑得太厉害了。我喜欢每一分钟。还有珍娜，Earwolf的一位音响工程师，乔丹·达菲，要唱《屁之全蚀》。
Now she did an inspired version off of what Paul wrote. She might have added in some fart sounds. Let's hear it. Farts are coming out on my bus. I need to fight. And I need to fall. And I need to fall. I need to fight
她根据保罗写的歌词做了一个灵感版本。她可能加了一些放屁的声音。我们来听听。屁从我的车里冒出来。我需要战斗。我需要坠落。我需要坠落。我需要战斗
and I need to fall Every now and then I could have fought Well done guys Thank you so much for bringing these Michael Parody songs to life You know, I have to say
我需要坠落。时不时地，我本可以战斗。做得好，伙计们。非常感谢你们让这些迈克尔的戏仿歌曲变得鲜活起来。你知道，我不得不说
Especially Total Eclipse of the Fart It really took me back Do you remember the Dan band? Yes I freaking love the Dan band I saw them live many times Guys, you know that Adam Sandler movie The Wedding Singer?
特别是《屁之全蚀》，它真的让我回到了过去。你还记得丹乐队吗？记得。我超级喜欢丹乐队。我现场看过他们很多次。伙计们，你们知道亚当·桑德勒的那部电影《婚礼歌手》吗？
Mm-hmm. The Dan Band is featured in the wedding singer, and they are just like this amazing cover band. They do all these hits from the 80s, but, you know, they kind of curse through them and stuff, and they put all these comedy bits in them, and they actually do a total eclipse of the heart that is a showstopper. Check it out on YouTube. You'll love it. I love it. That's what it made me think of.
嗯。丹乐队在《婚礼歌手》中出现过，他们就像是一个很棒的翻唱乐队。他们翻唱所有80年代的热门歌曲，但是，你知道，他们会在歌里加点脏话之类的，还会加入很多喜剧元素，他们实际上翻唱的《心之全蚀》简直是全场焦点。去YouTube上看看吧。你会喜欢的。我喜欢。这就是它让我想到的。
I love it. Well, we also got a fan question from Carolyn W. and Ashley W. who are the other musicians in Daryl's band? Oh, great question. Are they the same band from Booz Cruise? No, the band from Boos Cruz is different. The guys in this band were the guys in Craig Robinson's real band in real life. Oh, that's great.
我喜欢。好吧，我们还收到了卡罗琳·W和阿什利·W的粉丝提问，达里尔乐队里的其他音乐家是谁？哦，好问题。他们是《酒水巡游》里的那个乐队吗？不，《酒水巡游》里的乐队是不同的。这个乐队里的家伙是克雷格·罗宾逊现实生活中的真实乐队成员。哦，那太棒了。
On bass is his brother, Chris Robb. The drummer is Asa Watkins, and David Sampson is on guitar. And I remember Angela Steve did a lot of improvising during this scene. He did one whole bit where he danced. He took a big dance break. During one of them, he took the guitar and, like, did a full-on guitar solo. It was amazing. They had so much to choose from.
贝斯手是他弟弟克里斯·罗布。鼓手是阿萨·沃特金斯，大卫·桑普森弹吉他。我记得安吉拉，史蒂夫在这一幕中做了很多即兴表演。他有一整段戏是在跳舞。他来了一段很长的舞蹈。在其中一段里，他拿过吉他，来了一段完整的吉他独奏。太神奇了。他们有太多素材可以选择了。
Was any of that stuff in the deleted scenes? No, it wasn't. Oh. I know. But there's so much there. There's footage of Steve just going off. And on a crazy hot day in a suit. And he is just freaking giving Toby the send-off of the year.
那些东西有在删减片段里吗？没有，没有。哦。我知道。但那里有很多素材。有史蒂夫即兴发挥的镜头。在炎热的天气里穿着西装。他简直是在给托比送上年度最棒的告别。
I was hot just sitting and watching it. I can't imagine what that was like for Steve. But when I was watching this with Lee, he said one of his favorite things about this episode was the way we had that harsh back sun beating down on Steve and all of us. He said, I've been at those things. I've been at those company events and you're hot and you're sitting at the little table. And we're all having to cover our eyes even. to see? Yes. He thought that was so great. And he pointed out so many times in television and movies,
我光是坐着看都觉得热。我无法想象史蒂夫当时是什么感觉。但当我和李一起看这一集时，他说他最喜欢这一集的地方之一就是我们让那种刺眼的背光照在史蒂夫和我们所有人身上。他说，我参加过那种活动。我参加过那种公司活动，天气很热，你坐在小桌子旁。我们甚至不得不遮住眼睛才能看清？是的。他觉得这太棒了。他指出在电视和电影中，
they don't do that. They don't have like that harsh beating sun. Oh, no. They'll tarp things or they'll they'll, they'll like shoot at that golden hour where everyone looks amazing and no one has to squint. He thought it was a real nod to the authenticity of the documentary style of the show. And I was like, oh my gosh, you're right. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you know, your husband's looking at it with a director's eye, and that's such a great catch. And there is a talking head in the script that's not in the deleted scenes where after this whole crazy performance, Michael's like, you know what? I've just got to sweat Toby out. I'm sweating him out. Well, Pam has a very sweet talking head. She says that she's going to miss Toby because he was a calming presence in the office.
他们通常不会那样做。他们不会有那种刺眼的阳光。哦，不。他们会用遮阳布，或者他们会选择在黄金时刻拍摄，那样每个人看起来都很棒，也不用眯着眼睛。他认为这是对该剧纪录片风格真实性的一种致敬。我当时就说，天哪，你说得对。是啊。是啊。好吧，你知道，你丈夫是用导演的眼光在看，这真是个很棒的发现。剧本里有一个谈话头镜头没有出现在删减片段里，在这一整场疯狂的表演之后，迈克尔说，你知道吗？我得把托比从我身体里排出去。我正在把他排出去。好吧，帕姆有一个非常甜蜜的谈话头镜头。她说她会想念托比，因为他是办公室里一个冷静的存在。
And then if only Toby could hear, she says, don't tell him I said this, but I always thought he was kind of cute. Oh, you know, years later, Toby's going to see this and, like, fall off his chair. Oh, my gosh. Well, there's a series of deleted talking heads where people sort of talk about their relationship to Toby, what they'll remember about Toby. But there's one in the script that didn't make it to the deleted scenes that I have to share with you. It's Oscar. and he says, well, the Finer Things Club is going to have a spot to fill. Our candidates are Kevin Stanley, Angela Kelly, Meredith Creed.
然后如果托比能听到的话，她说，别告诉他我说了这些，但我一直觉得他挺可爱的。哦，你知道，多年后，托比看到这个会从椅子上掉下来的。天哪。好吧，有一系列被删减的谈话头镜头，人们谈论他们与托比的关系，他们会记住托比的什么。但剧本里有一个没能进入删减片段的镜头，我必须和你分享。是奥斯卡。他说，好吧，高雅事物俱乐部要填补一个空缺了。我们的候选人是凯文、斯坦利、安吉拉、凯利、梅雷迪斯、克里德。
We may have to change it to just the Things Club. Because of one of those people joins that they're not going to be finer anymore. That's right. That's right. Listening to that list, I don't want to be in a club with any of those people. Truly, none of them is going to take. the material seriously. Oh, are they going to have too many objections? Angela's going to not want to read half the books you want to read.
我们可能得把它改名为“事物俱乐部”了。因为如果这些人中的任何一个加入，他们就不再“高雅”了。没错。没错。听听那个名单，我不想和这些人中的任何一个待在一个俱乐部里。真的，他们中没有一个人会认真对待这些材料。哦，他们会有太多的反对意见吗？安吉拉会不想读你想要读的一半书。
I know. All right. Well, there's a very cute Michael Holly flirty flirt scene. She's saying she'd love to hear beers in heaven. And he's like, hey, too soon. Kind of sexual. During this whole conversation in the background, 31 minutes, 19 seconds, you can see Stanley and he's dancing by the band.
我知道。好吧。有一个非常可爱的迈克尔和霍莉调情的场景。她说她很想听《天堂里的啤酒》。他说，嘿，太早了。有点色情。在整个谈话过程中，在背景里，31分19秒，你可以看到斯坦利在乐队旁边跳舞。
It's so cute. Amazing. Well, during this scene, Michael gets a phone call from Kevin, who's at the supermarket and says you need to get down here immediately, immediately. So Michael's like, all right. When he gets to the supermarket, he finds out why Kevin called him. Jan is there. Mm-hmm. And Jan is pregnant. Yeah.
太可爱了。太棒了。好吧，在这一幕中，迈克尔接到了凯文的电话，凯文在超市里说你需要立刻、马上过来。所以迈克尔说，好吧。当他到达超市时，他发现了凯文叫他的原因。简在那里。嗯。而且简怀孕了。是啊。
Regnant. Jan plus one is there. Fan question from Dorothy Jay. Was Malora Harden actually pregnant or was it a fake belly? It was a fake belly. Mm-hmm. Malora has two daughters, but they were very much born by this point. Very much born.
怀孕了。简加一号在那里。多萝西·J的粉丝提问。马洛拉·哈登是真的怀孕了还是假肚子？那是假肚子。嗯。马洛拉有两个女儿，但到这个时候她们已经出生很久了。出生很久了。
They were. They were not in the belly anymore. No. Jan and Michael are going to catch up. Yeah. Michael is so happy. He's deliriously happy. But Jan says you're not the father.
她们确实出生了。她们不在肚子里了。不。简和迈克尔要叙叙旧。是啊。迈克尔非常高兴。他高兴得神魂颠倒。但简说你不是孩子的父亲。
No. And Michael says you cheated on me when I specifically asked you not to. he also shares that they were very cautious and he had to wear two condoms. Yeah. But the timing, it's clear that this pregnancy happened while they were still together. And she explains, that is true. We were together. But I went to a sperm bank.
不。迈克尔说你在我明确要求你不要这样做的时候背叛了我。他还分享说他们非常谨慎，他不得不戴两个避孕套。是啊。但时间上，很明显这次怀孕发生在我们还在一起的时候。她解释说，那是真的。我们当时在一起。但我去了精子库。
A really good one. Not just any sperm bank. It's the really, really good one next to the IHop. Yeah. Jenna, in the script, and it didn't make it to the deleted scenes. Jan reveals whose sperm she bought. What? Yeah.
一个非常好的精子库。不仅仅是随便哪个精子库。是IHop隔壁那个非常、非常好的精子库。是啊。珍娜，在剧本里，而且没能进入删减片段，简透露了她买了谁的精子。什么？是啊。
Whose sperm is it? Jan says, you have to pay top dollar, but it's worth it. Now, here's the best part. I got Andy Rodic sperm. What? Yeah, and Jan looks to Michael like she's expecting him to be very impressed. And Michael says, the tennis player? And Jan says, well, it's a little more than that.
是谁的精子？简说，你必须花大价钱，但这是值得的。现在，最棒的部分来了。我买了安迪·罗迪克的精子。什么？是啊，简看着迈克尔，好像她期待他会印象深刻。迈克尔说，那个网球运动员？简说，嗯，不仅仅是那样。
He's the sixth ranked player in the world, and he's won four grand slams. And Michael says, that's a lot of grand slams, I guess. And Jan says, and he's a humanitarian, something with orphans. And Michael is quiet. And Jan goes, Michael? And Michael says, can I just sit here for a minute without more things coming into my head? Okay. You guys, Andy Roddick was friends with Rain Wilson, and he was a big fan of the office, and he came by the set.
他是世界排名第六的选手，赢过四个大满贯。迈克尔说，我想那确实是很多大满贯。简说，而且他还是个人道主义者，做过一些孤儿相关的事。迈克尔沉默了。简说，迈克尔？迈克尔说，我能在这里坐一会儿，别再往我脑子里塞东西了吗？好吧。伙计们，安迪·罗迪克是雷恩·威尔森的朋友，他是《办公室》的忠实粉丝，他来过片场。
I have to imagine that the reason they wrote it as being Andy Roddick sperm was a little bit of a nod to Andy, who has an amazing sense of humor. Me and Lee got to know Andy and Brooklyn through our love of tennis. We would go watch Andy play tennis and sit with Brooklyn. And oh my gosh, I am so sad for his sake that this did not stay in the episode because. I know. I got to know Brooklyn myself through some charity work. And I was like, I kind of want to text her. couplet of dialogue. I was cracking up. So Andy Rodic is the father of Jan's baby. Incredible.
我不得不认为他们把它写成安迪·罗迪克的精子是对安迪的一种致敬，他很有幽默感。我和李通过我们对网球的热爱在布鲁克林认识了安迪。我们会去看安迪打网球，和布鲁克林坐在一起。天哪，我真为他感到难过，因为这段对话没有留在剧集里。我知道。我通过一些慈善工作认识了布鲁克林。我当时想，我真想给她发个短信。那段对话让我笑喷了。所以安迪·罗迪克是简孩子的父亲。不可思议。
Incredible. Anyway, that's in the shooting draft. It didn't make it to the screen or the deleted scenes, but I thought that was hilarious and I had to share. Well, Jan tells Michael, I'm so happy I've gotten this off my chest. And by the way, if you want to come to my Lamas class, I'd love to have you there. But Michael says, I need to think about it. I need to think about it. And he has this talking head where he says his whole life he's known two things. He loves sex and he wants to have kids. He always thought those things would go hand in hand.
不可思议。总之，那是在拍摄剧本里。它没能出现在屏幕上或删减片段里，但我认为那太搞笑了，我必须分享。好吧，简告诉迈克尔，我很高兴我把这件事说出来了。顺便说一下，如果你想来参加我的拉玛泽课程，我很乐意让你参加。但迈克尔说，我需要考虑一下。我需要考虑一下。他有一个谈话头镜头，说他一生中只知道两件事。他喜欢性，他想要孩子。他一直以为这两件事会齐头并进。
But, you know, now it's one or the other. So Michael does this talking head standing outside of the supermarket and we put up a sign that it was a Garrity supermarket. And that is a real supermarket, a family-run grocery store chain in Pennsylvania. And I looked it up, Angela, and it is so charming and amazing. Yeah. You go to their website and you can click on this thing on their website that says, who is mom? Who is mom?
但是，你知道，现在只能二选一了。所以迈克尔在超市外做了这个谈话头镜头，我们挂了一个牌子，显示那是加里蒂超市。那是一家真正的超市，是宾夕法尼亚州一家家族经营的连锁杂货店。我查了一下，安吉拉，它太迷人、太棒了。是啊。你访问他们的网站，你可以点击网站上写着“谁是妈妈？”的东西。谁是妈妈？
I was intrigued. I clicked. And it explains that Garrities is run by Joyce Mom Fasula. She is the president and CEO of Garrities. That's why their slogan is, Garrities, where moms in charge. She was born in 1947 in Scranton. She graduated from Maywood University with a master's in counseling and education, and she was a teacher at North Pocono School District. Then, in 1971, she married Neil Fasula, and he ran the family grocery business.
我很好奇。我点击了。它解释说加里蒂是由乔伊斯·“妈妈”·法苏拉经营的。她是加里蒂的总裁兼首席执行官。这就是为什么他们的口号是，“加里蒂，妈妈当家”。她于1947年出生在斯克兰顿。她从梅伍德大学获得了咨询和教育硕士学位，曾是北波科诺学区的老师。然后，在1971年，她嫁给了尼尔·法苏拉，他经营着家族杂货生意。
She left teaching to raise her two sons, but when her husband Neil passed away in 1997, she took over the grocery business. Garrides is the largest family-owned supermarket business in northeastern Pennsylvania, and it is one of the largest, in the country that is owned by a mom. But wait, there's more. Okay. Perhaps you'd like to click on the button titled, Who is Aunt Mary? Who is Aunt Mary?
她离开教学岗位去抚养她的两个儿子，但当她的丈夫尼尔在1997年去世时，她接管了杂货生意。加里蒂是宾夕法尼亚州东北部最大的家族经营超市企业，也是全国由妈妈拥有的最大的超市之一。但等等，还有更多。好吧。也许你想点击标题为“谁是玛丽阿姨？”的按钮。谁是玛丽阿姨？
Well, Aunt Mary is Joyce's mother-in-law, Mary Fasula. And long before her son Neil started the grocery business, Mary would make all of her family recipes and sell them to local businesses and restaurants in Scranton. She made pasta, sauces, meatballs, and Italian cookies. When people asked who made this, the shop owners would say, oh, that's our Aunt Mary. Well, the name stuck, and when her son started his grocery business, she started a brand called Aunt Mary's Kitchen, and they sold her stuff at the grocery store.
好吧，玛丽阿姨是乔伊斯的婆婆，玛丽·法苏拉。早在她儿子尼尔开始杂货生意之前，玛丽就会制作她所有的家庭食谱，并把它们卖给斯克兰顿当地的企业和餐馆。她制作意大利面、酱汁、肉丸和意大利饼干。当人们问是谁做的时，店主会说，哦，那是我们的玛丽阿姨。好吧，这个名字就传开了，当她儿子开始他的杂货生意时，她创立了一个叫“玛丽阿姨厨房”的品牌，他们在杂货店里卖她的东西。
And I'll have you know, I looked it up, they still sell her Italian cookies in the bakery, and they still sell her meatballs and stuffing in the deli. I love it. I went on their website as well. I love the whole story, how it started in 1895 with William. Gary and then Neil Fasula started working there as a delivery boy in the 60s. It's just been a family-owned business passed down and I want to go there. Let's put it on the tour list.
我得告诉你，我查过了，他们现在还在烘焙店卖她的意大利饼干，在熟食店卖她的肉丸和馅料。我喜欢。我也访问了他们的网站。我喜欢整个故事，它是如何从1895年威廉·加里开始的，然后尼尔·法苏拉在60年代开始在那里做送货员。这只是一个代代相传的家族企业，我想去那里。把它加到旅游清单上吧。
Let's put it on the tour list. I want to meet mom. I want to meet mom. Guys, back at the party, the fireworks have started. They're very exciting, very romantic. We got a fan question from Hudson M. were the fireworks real or were they special effects? They were real.
把它加到旅游清单上吧。我想见见妈妈。我想见见妈妈。伙计们，回到派对上，烟花开始了。非常令人兴奋，非常浪漫。我们收到了哈德森·M的粉丝提问，烟花是真的还是特效？它们是真的。
Kentapedia told me we spent, are you ready for it? Oh no. How much money? $11,000. How much? $11,000 on the fireworks. Holy moly. Yeah.
肯塔百科告诉我我们花了，你准备好了吗？哦，不。多少钱？11,000美元。多少？11,000美元买烟花。天哪。是啊。
And we launched them in the field where we used to have like overflow parking. We cleared out the parking lot and that's where they shot them off. So the fireworks are going off. People are impressed, except Angela Martin, who tells Phyllis, she will never plan another party again. Why not? It was a great party. Ease up, Angela. She's not having it. Guys, Jim gets the ring out of his pocket. He's holding it. He's hiding it. He's about to propose. This is going to be amazing. And I'm going to make us take a break. We'll tell you what happens in just a moment.
我们在以前用来做溢流停车场的田野里发射了它们。我们清理了停车场，那就是他们发射烟花的地方。所以烟花正在燃放。人们印象深刻，除了安吉拉·马丁，她告诉菲利斯，她再也不会策划任何派对了。为什么不？那是个很棒的派对。放轻松点，安吉拉。她不买账。伙计们，吉姆从口袋里掏出了戒指。他拿着它。他藏着它。他正要求婚。这会很棒的。我要让我们休息一下。我们一会儿告诉你们发生了什么。
a second. Okay, guys, we're back. Remember, Jim's got a ring in his hand. He's going to propose. He's going to do it. He's going to do it. And then? And then Andy grabs the microphone. His parents are there. There's fireworks. This is the moment. All right, we had a fan question from Gena C and Chelsea B. There are a lot of spoilers in this. So if for some reason you've not seen the whole series, just fast forward 50 seconds. Here's what they have to say. What is the deal with Andy's family? When we see Andy's parents again in season eight Garden Party, they are different actors and they have different names. This is true. In season six, Andy says if it weren't for secretaries, he wouldn't have a stepmom. In season five, Andy says there's a place that parents decided not to get divorced. So what is happening? In season nine,
一秒钟。好了，伙计们，我们回来了。记住，吉姆手里有戒指。他要求婚了。他要做了。他要做了。然后呢？然后安迪抢过了麦克风。他的父母在那里。有烟花。就是这一刻。好吧，我们收到了吉娜·C和切尔西·B的粉丝提问。这里面有很多剧透。所以如果因为某种原因你还没看过整部剧，就快进50秒。这是他们要说的。安迪的家庭是怎么回事？当我们在第八季《花园派对》中再次见到安迪的父母时，他们是不同的演员，名字也不同。这是真的。在第六季中，安迪说如果不是因为秘书，他就不会有继母。在第五季中，安迪说有一个地方父母决定不离婚。所以发生了什么？在第九季，
Andy's dad leaves with all the family money and a younger woman. And then Wikipedia says that his mom died and the woman we meet is his stepmom. But they're like, we don't remember that. They said, frankly, every time we talk about Andy's family, it's different. What is going on? Can you check the show Bible? Please, please. Can you give us any clarity?
安迪的爸爸带着所有的家庭财产和一个年轻女人离开了。然后维基百科说他妈妈去世了，我们见到的那个女人是他继母。但他们就像是，我们不记得了。他们说，坦率地说，每次我们谈论安迪的家庭，情况都不一样。到底发生了什么？你能查查剧集圣经吗？拜托，拜托。你能给我们一点清晰的解释吗？
I'm guessing no one entered anything in the show Bible and they kept making things up and people couldn't remember what's going on. Well, Angela, you would be correct. I talked to Jen Salata about it. She said, here's what happened. Andy's parents were seen briefly in this episode as extras. But when it came time to bring them on for real, they had to be cast. So they had to hire actors to do these speaking roles. They held auditions.
我猜没人往剧集圣经里输入任何东西，他们一直在编造，人们记不住发生了什么。好吧，安吉拉，你说对了。我和简·萨拉塔谈过这件事。她说，事情是这样的。安迪的父母在这一集中作为临时演员短暂出现过。但当真正需要他们出场时，他们必须被选角。所以他们不得不雇佣演员来扮演这些有台词的角色。他们举行了试镜。
And that's why they changed. She said, as far as all of the other inconsistencies, she says, I have no idea. Just clearly we were not paying attention and we were just writing what was funniest. She said she really believes that Genesee and Chelsea B should work in continuity. She commends their question. Yes, great job. Well, guys, since his parents are there, this set of parents at least, he is going to propose to Angela. He asked her to come up on stage.
这就是为什么他们换人了。她说，至于所有其他的不一致之处，她说，我不知道。显然我们没注意，我们只是在写最有趣的东西。她说她真的认为吉娜·C和切尔西·B应该从事连续性工作。她称赞了他们的问题。是的，干得好。好吧，伙计们，既然他的父母在那里，至少这组父母在，他要向安吉拉求婚了。他让她上台。
She won't go. So he's going to drag the microphone and keyboard to her. Yeah, he's going to wreck Daryl's keyboard and go to his lady. Yeah. You can see my belly in this shot. Oh, for sure. In this whole scene, I'm just pregnant and no one cares. I loved shooting this scene. Angela, I loved that the reason your character says she won't get up is because you couldn't get up or we would see your belly. But it's one of those moments where real life they had to fix that. Why wouldn't Angela get up? So they write this great joke that she refuses to stand, which is just so funny, which I'm not sure they would have thought of if not for the problem of you not being able to stand.
她不肯去。所以他要把麦克风和键盘拖到她身边。是啊，他要毁了达里尔的键盘，去找他的女士。是啊。在这个镜头里你可以看到我的肚子。哦，肯定的。在这一整幕里，我怀孕了，没人关心。我喜欢拍摄这一幕。安吉拉，我喜欢你角色说她不上台的原因是因为你站不起来，否则我们就会看到你的肚子。但这是现实生活中他们不得不解决的时刻之一。为什么安吉拉不上台？所以他们写了这个很棒的笑话，她拒绝站起来，这太搞笑了，如果不是因为你站不起来的问题，我不确定他们是否会想到这一点。
Yeah. I love that. I loved when he was like, will you marry me? And my character's like, okay. And then he's like, into the microphone, babe. I'm like, I said okay. Can you imagine if you ask someone to marry them and their answer was, I said okay? With a bite to it.
是啊。我喜欢那个。我喜欢当他说，你愿意嫁给我吗？我的角色说，好吧。然后他说，对着麦克风说，宝贝。我说，我说了好吧。你能想象如果你向某人求婚，他们的回答是“我说了好吧”吗？带着一种刺。
I said okay. And the crowd goes wild. I know. Kelly runs up and says, can I be a bridesmaid? Oh, yeah. And Angela's like, no. In the script, there was an Angela talking head after the proposal. First of all, in the script, she starts off the talking head by showing off the engagement ring.
我说了好吧。人群疯狂了。我知道。凯利跑上来问，我可以当伴娘吗？哦，是的。安吉拉说，不。在剧本里，求婚后有一个安吉拉的谈话头镜头。首先，在剧本里，她通过展示订婚戒指开始了谈话头镜头。
It is written that it is a giant yellow diamond with a huge inclusion. If you were wondering. Okay. And then here's Angela's talking head. I don't like options in life. Options make me jittery and crazy. like I just had a cup of green tea. I like order.
上面写着那是一颗巨大的黄色钻石，有一个巨大的内含物。如果你想知道的话。好吧。这是安吉拉的谈话头镜头。我不喜欢生活中有选择。选择让我紧张和疯狂。就像我刚喝了一杯绿茶。我喜欢秩序。
I like answers. I like knowing this is where you'll work. This is what you'll wear. This is what you'll come home to. Great. Done. Let's get married. I love you too.
我喜欢答案。我喜欢知道这就是你工作的地方。这就是你要穿的衣服。这就是你要回到的地方。很好。完成了。我们结婚吧。我也爱你。
Says it all. That's all you need to know. She's ordering her life. And I think Dwight is too unpredictable. You just don't know with him and she can't control him. And, you know, she came home to a dead frozen cat. And she'll have none of those shenanigans ever again. Well, certainly not with anything.
说明了一切。这就是你需要知道的全部。她在整理她的生活。而且我觉得德怀特太不可预测了。你就是不知道他会怎么样，她无法控制他。而且，你知道，她回到家发现了一只死掉的冷冻猫。她再也不会容忍那些胡闹了。好吧，当然不是和任何事情。
Andy. She is the boss of Andy for sure. This is a very comfortable, predictable relationship. That's right. On her terms. Completely. Well, guys, Jim puts the ring away. He is not going to propose on the same night in the same place that Andy proposes. And Pam seems to be a little bit upset. I have to say, good call, Jim. Well, yeah. I mean, Pam is upset, but she's got to know. Wait, Jim is like a smart guy and there's no way he would propose to me after that crazy overture from Andy in front of everyone.
安迪。她绝对是安迪的老板。这是一个非常舒适、可预测的关系。没错。按照她的条件。完全是。好吧，伙计们，吉姆把戒指收起来了。他不会在安迪求婚的同一个晚上、同一个地方求婚。帕姆似乎有点难过。我不得不说，好决定，吉姆。好吧，是啊。我是说，帕姆很难过，但她一定知道。等等，吉姆是个聪明人，他不可能在安迪当着所有人的面做出那种疯狂的举动后向我求婚。
You don't want that as a part of your engagement story when you go out to dinner and all that jazz and also I do want to say, I don't know, did Jim have time to like call her parents and ask for her hand in marriage because this seems a little traditional to me. There is a scene in the script where Jim is trying to call Pam's mom
当你出去吃晚饭等等的时候，你不想让那成为你订婚故事的一部分，而且我也想说，我不知道，吉姆有时间打电话给她父母请求她的手吗？因为这对我来说似乎有点传统。剧本里有一个场景，吉姆试图给帕姆的妈妈打电话
and is leaving her a message And he's just like, hey, I've tried you a few times, just need to get a hold of you. So Jim was trying to call your mom. Okay. Yeah. I like that. I don't know who's more bummed, Pam or Dwight. I think Dwight.
并给她留了言。他说，嘿，我试过几次了，只是需要联系你。所以吉姆是在试图给你妈妈打电话。好吧。是啊。我喜欢那个。我不知道谁更沮丧，帕姆还是德怀特。我觉得是德怀特。
Yeah. He's really, really sad. He actually says, well, it's my own fault. Yeah. But Pam is pretty bummed, and it's right at this moment that Toby is going to try to take a picture with her. Yeah. He's got this fancy camera, which I do remember there's a whole deleted scene where he has purchased this fancy camera. Suddenly.
是啊。他真的、真的很伤心。他实际上说，好吧，这是我自己的错。是啊。但帕姆很沮丧，就在这一刻，托比试图和她合影。是啊。他有这个高级相机，我确实记得有一个完整的删减片段，他买了这台高级相机。突然间。
It's really funny, you guys. I filmed it and I texted it to Paul because it made me laugh so hard. He comes in with this camera and he asks Jim, he's like, hey, picture? And Jim and Pam are at reception talking. And Jim and Pam are like, sure. And they start posing for Toby to take pictures of them. And they're like, smiley, silly one. crazy one. And like, Toby is like, oh, God, and he just walks away. It's so funny. But he's clearly
真的很有趣，伙计们。我拍了它，并把它发给了保罗，因为它让我笑得太厉害了。他带着这台相机进来，问吉姆，他说，嘿，拍张照？吉姆和帕姆在接待处聊天。吉姆和帕姆说，当然。他们开始摆姿势让托比给他们拍照。他们就像是，笑一个，傻一点的。疯狂一点的。然后托比就像是，哦，天哪，他就走开了。太搞笑了。但他显然
gone out and he's pretending like he bought it for Costa Rica. But the truth is he's bought this very fancy camera so he could get a picture with Pam. It's finally going to happen. Yeah. Meredith takes a picture. She says, Pam, your smile is weird. She's distracted by her non-proposal that just happened. But Toby is delighted. You see him later just like sitting and scrolling through these pictures of him and Pam. Right about this time, Michael gets back to the party and Holly tells him all about what happened. Andy proposed to an accountant. And Michael says, well, it could have been Oscar or Angela, really.
出去了，他假装是为哥斯达黎加买的。但事实是他买了这台非常高级的相机，这样他就能和帕姆合影。终于要发生了。是啊。梅雷迪斯拍了一张照片。她说，帕姆，你的笑容很奇怪。她被刚才发生的非求婚事件分心了。但托比很高兴。你后来看到他只是坐在那里翻看这些他和帕姆的照片。就在这个时候，迈克尔回到了派对，霍莉告诉了他发生的一切。安迪向一个会计求婚了。迈克尔说，好吧，那可能是奥斯卡或安吉拉，真的。
Yes. He could see either one happening. And that's when Holly opens the door. She says, gosh, even after. After all these ribs and this whole party, I'm still a little hungry, I thought maybe I'd go get some dessert. Michael says, oh, you should go to the glider diner. Ask Stanley about it. He goes there all the time.
是的。他能看出这两种情况中的任何一种。就在这时，霍莉打开了门。她说，天哪，即使在吃了这么多排骨和整个派对之后，我还是有点饿，我想也许我该去吃点甜点。迈克尔说，哦，你应该去滑翔机餐馆。问问斯坦利。他经常去那里。
And she's like, oh, oh, okay. Well, Michael is distracted. Yeah. He has just had such a huge life curveball thrown at him. He's just not there in the moment with her. Well, Kevin's there in the moment. He overhears. He says, let's go.
她说，哦，哦，好的。好吧，迈克尔分心了。是啊。他刚刚被生活投出了一个巨大的曲线球。他现在和她在一起时不在状态。好吧，凯文在那里。他听到了。他说，我们走吧。
She's like, great. That's terrific. So now she's going to go off and have dessert with Kevin. Angela, I looked up the glider diner. It's a real place. Oh, yeah? Oh, yeah. It's in downtown Scranton.
她说，太好了。那太棒了。所以现在她要和凯文去吃甜点了。安吉拉，我查了滑翔机餐馆。那是个真实的地方。哦，是吗？哦，是的。它在斯克兰顿市中心。
It's right across from the Scranton Memorial Stadium. It was opened in 1945 by Chappie LaStrange and the late Jean Cosgrove Senior. Chappie LaStrains. That is a name and then some. I love it. What about his partner, Gene Cosgrove Senior? I mean, come on these two. These are great names. Chappie and Gene.
它就在斯克兰顿纪念体育场对面。它是由查皮·拉斯特兰奇和已故的吉恩·科斯格罗夫高级在1945年开设的。查皮·拉斯特兰奇。那是个名字，而且很有特色。我喜欢。那他的合伙人吉恩·科斯格罗夫高级呢？我是说，拜托，这两个人。这些名字太棒了。查皮和吉恩。
They were both in the service together, and when they got out, they decided they wanted to go in the restaurant business. It was tough times at first. Chappie had to sell tires on the side to keep things going, but it succeeded, and the restaurant is still run by Chappie and his son Charlie. This was any inspiration for what's coming ahead in work bus where Laverne's pies and tires? I wonder! This is a diner, and he had to sell tires on the side. It's very possible. The glider diner is open seven days a week, and they're open until 10 p.m. Monday through Saturday.
他们俩一起服役，当他们退伍时，他们决定进入餐饮业。起初日子很艰难。查皮不得不私下卖轮胎来维持生意，但它成功了，餐馆现在仍由查皮和他的儿子查理经营。这是否是《工作巴士》中拉弗恩的馅饼和轮胎的灵感来源？我想知道！这是一家餐馆，他不得不私下卖轮胎。很有可能。滑翔机餐馆每周七天营业，周一到周六营业到晚上10点。
So don't worry. Holly and Kevin have plenty of time to get dessert, and here are their choices. I looked up the desserts. They can have rice pudding, baked pie, cake slice, baked pie with ice cream, tapioca pudding, ice cream, a pudding, ice cream Sunday, ice cream, or special dessert. Lady, can we add this to the tour list? And can I just propose that we get special dessert? Whatever it is, we're ordering special dessert at the glider diner.
所以别担心。霍莉和凯文有足够的时间去吃甜点，这是他们的选择。我查了甜点。他们可以吃米布丁、烤馅饼、蛋糕片、带冰淇淋的烤馅饼、木薯布丁、冰淇淋、布丁、冰淇淋圣代、冰淇淋或特色甜点。女士，我们可以把它加到旅游清单上吗？我可以提议我们点特色甜点吗？不管它是什么，我们要在滑翔机餐馆点特色甜点。
We're going to go spend like two weeks in Pennsylvania if we're going to go hit all the spots. We really are. I want to have some of Aunt Mary's meatballs over at Garrity's, and then we're going to finish it off with some special dessert at Glider Diner. Mm-hmm. Even though Michael is distracted by Jan and the new baby bump, he's going to remember it's time for Toby to go. And he's going to grab Hank the security guard and they're going to escort him out of the dam building. Lady, is there anyone better than Hank? No, Hank's the best. He has like one line. And it's just everything about the way he's standing, his body language. Yeah. All of it. Perfect. Hugh Dane was just fantastic. He was just perfect. And as they're walking out, Toby's watch has an alarm that goes off.
如果我们要去打卡所有景点，我们得在宾夕法尼亚州待上两周。我们真的得去。我想在加里蒂吃一些玛丽阿姨的肉丸，然后我们要以滑翔机餐馆的特色甜点结束。嗯。尽管迈克尔被简和新的孕肚分心了，但他会记得托比该走了。他会抓住汉克保安，他们会护送他离开大楼。女士，还有比汉克更好的人吗？不，汉克是最棒的。他只有一句台词。他站立的方式、肢体语言，一切都说明了一切。是啊。所有的一切。完美。休·戴恩真是太棒了。他简直完美。当他们走出去时，托比的手表闹钟响了。
Well, remember, Michael said it in the morning to the moment that Toby would leave. Mm-hmm. And now he's finally gone. And there is this great Michael talking head. We clearly shot it upstairs in the rider's offices because the Ferris wheel is rotating. You can see the lights out the window. It's really pretty. It's really a nice shot.
好吧，记住，迈克尔早上说了托比离开的那一刻。嗯。现在他终于走了。有一个很棒的迈克尔谈话头镜头。我们显然是在楼上的编剧办公室拍摄的，因为摩天轮在旋转。你可以看到窗外的灯光。真的很漂亮。这真是一个很好的镜头。
And he's decided to go to Jan's Lamaz class. And he says, you know, if there are any details you need to fill me in on, like what exactly Lamaz is, that would be great. Well, as if this episode didn't have enough, we've got this tag. Ooh, boy. Oh, boy. Phyllis is in the elevator. She's talking to camera. She is so excited about how her party went.
他决定去参加简的拉玛泽课程。他说，你知道，如果有什么细节你需要告诉我，比如拉玛泽到底是什么，那就太好了。好吧，好像这一集还不够多，我们还有这个片尾彩蛋。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。菲利斯在电梯里。她在和摄像机说话。她对她的派对进行得如何感到非常兴奋。
She says party planning is like a runner's high. It's just, oh, her adrenaline, right? But then she overhears a noise, Angela, in the office. Mm-hmm. And she walks in the front door and tell us what does she see. Oh, my gosh, she sees Dwight and Angela, like, in the throes of passion. You guys don't have clothes on. What is going on?
她说派对策划就像跑步者的快感。这只是，哦，她的肾上腺素，对吧？但随后她听到了一种声音，安吉拉，在办公室里。嗯。她走进前门，告诉我们她看到了什么。天哪，她看到德怀特和安吉拉，就像，在激情之中。你们没穿衣服。发生了什么？
Well, lady. Just talk to Paul Feig about how difficult filming this scene was. In the script, it says Phyllis walks in and sees Dwight and Angela having sex. Hey, how do you do that? A, network television, B, when the female actress is incredibly pregnant, right? So poor Paul. I feel like Paul Fee always had to deal with awkward stuff with Dwight and Angela and figure out how best to show it, right? We had a whole rehearsal with camera with no one else in the bullpen where we tried to simulate a sexy looking shot and it was impossible. You could not hide my belly. So what they decided to do is, A, rain has his shirt off.
好吧，女士。去和保罗·费格谈谈拍摄这一幕有多困难。剧本里说菲利斯走进来看到德怀特和安吉拉在做爱。嘿，你怎么做那个？A，电视网，B，当女演员怀孕时，对吧？所以可怜的保罗。我觉得保罗·费格总是不得不处理德怀特和安吉拉尴尬的事情，并想出展示它的最好方法，对吧？我们和摄像机在没有其他人的情况下进行了一次完整的排练，我们试图模拟一个看起来性感的镜头，但这不可能。你无法隐藏我的肚子。所以他们决定做的是，A，雷恩脱掉了衬衫。
If you'll notice, all they did was take my hair down from the ponytail. And I have a few buttons undone, but I'm fully in my maternity romper. But here's the thing, Angela, your character was always so buttoned up that just to have like your declatage showing is so shocking. Well, and to have my hair down and all askew like that. For sure. So they decided rain shirt off was all they needed, me looking dishevelled. they did a very far away shot and they framed it over the file cabinet. But all they really needed was for Phyllis to see me and me to see Phyllis.
如果你注意到了，他们所做的只是把我的头发从马尾辫里放下来。我解开了几个扣子，但我完全穿着我的孕妇连体裤。但问题是，安吉拉，你的角色总是那么保守，仅仅是露出你的锁骨就太令人震惊了。好吧，还有把头发放下来，弄得那么乱。肯定的。所以他们决定雷恩脱掉衬衫就是他们所需要的，我看起来衣衫不整。他们拍了一个非常远的镜头，并把它框在文件柜上。但他们真正需要的只是菲利斯看到我，而我看到菲利斯。
And that was that. Well, Rain talked about rehearsing this scene, Angela. He said, yes, you tried a lot of different locations during your rehearsal. He said you guys tried having sex on the copy machine, on Creed's desk, on Michael's desk, on the mail cart, and on the floor by the file cabinets. Yes. That's a lot of places. We did.
事情就是这样。嗯，雷恩谈到了排练这一幕，安吉拉。他说，是的，你们在排练时尝试了很多不同的地点。他说你们试过在复印机上、克里德的桌子上、迈克尔的桌子上、邮件推车上，还有文件柜旁的地板上做爱。是的。那确实有很多地方。我们确实试过。
And here's the thing. You have Paul Feig. You have the camera crew. And we're just literally going around the office. Where could these two people be getting it on where you can't tell I'm pregnant? And I think what really sealed the deal on we have to have it more hidden behind the file cabinet is when we tried the floor. Paul Feig literally started laughing and said, okay, stop, stop. Well, Rayne also said that there was a very big discussion.
关键是，当时有保罗·费格在场，还有摄影组。我们真的就在办公室里到处转。这两个人能在哪里亲热而又让你看不出我怀孕了呢？我想真正决定必须把地点选在文件柜后面更隐蔽处的原因，是我们尝试在地板上的时候。保罗·费格直接笑了起来，说，好了，停，停。嗯，雷恩还说当时有过一场非常大的讨论。
over whether or not he should be wearing his glasses. Yes. Right? Because they'd taken your hair down, like you said. Uh-huh. Then they were like, would Dwight have taken off his glasses? They decided that they had to leave the glasses on so that there would be absolutely no doubt who you were having sex with.
关于他是否应该戴着眼镜。对吧？因为就像你说的，他们把你的头发放下来了。嗯哼。然后他们就在想，德怀特会摘掉眼镜吗？他们决定必须让他戴着眼镜，这样就绝对不会有人怀疑你在和谁做爱。
In Rain's words, who was straddling America's favorite accountant? That's what he said. Well, I took a screen grab of the moment they are busted and I think it's amazing. It's so good. It looks like a cover of a romance novel. I know, like a cheesy, cheesy romance novel. I'm going to put it in our stories. It's really good. Oh, will someone take that screen grab, please, after Angela posts it and turn that into the cover of a romance novel for me, please. Please. I'm begging you. That's pretty great. Well, you know, Jenna, this script would have ended with a Phyllis talking head. What? Yes, in the script, the final. moment of this episode is Phyllis, and she is described like this. Phyllis talking head.
用雷恩的话说，是谁骑在美国最受欢迎的会计师身上？他是这么说的。嗯，我截取了他们被抓包那一刻的画面，我觉得太棒了。真的太好了。看起来就像言情小说的封面。我知道，就像那种俗气的言情小说。我会把它发到我们的快拍里。真的很棒。哦，有人能在那张截图发出来后，帮我把它做成言情小说的封面吗，拜托了。拜托。我求你们了。那太棒了。嗯，你知道吗，珍娜，这个剧本原本是以菲利斯的单人访谈结束的。什么？是的，在剧本里，这一集的最后一刻是菲利斯，她是这样描述的。菲利斯单人访谈。
Phyllis is sitting back, relaxed and confident. You're looking at the new head of the party planning committee. I think I'll make Angela my assistant, so I don't have to do all the boring stuff. If she doesn't like it, I'm going to sing. I love it. I wish that stayed in. I know, I know. And you guys, that was goodbye, Toby.
菲利斯靠在椅背上，放松而自信。你们看到的是派对策划委员会的新负责人了。我想我会让安吉拉当我的助理，这样我就不用做那些无聊的事情了。如果她不喜欢，我就要唱歌了。我喜欢这个。真希望这一段能保留下来。我知道，我知道。伙计们，这就是《再见，托比》。
Part 2. And that wraps up season 4 of the office. I can't believe it. What's next? Weight loss. Season 5, weight loss. Holy moly. All right, well, we would like to thank Jen Salada, Paul Lieberstein, Kate Plannery,
第二部分。这就是《办公室》第四季的结尾。真不敢相信。接下来是什么？《减肥》。第五季，《减肥》。天哪。好吧，我们要感谢珍·萨拉达、保罗·利伯斯坦、凯特·弗兰纳里，
Rayne Wilson, and of course, Kent Zbornaq, for answering our questions for this episode. We love you guys. We'll see you in season 5. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
雷恩·威尔逊，当然还有肯特·兹博纳克，感谢他们回答了我们这一集的问题。我们爱你们。我们第五季见。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是凯西·尤金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。